this is jacqueline podcast number 327
with me jaco willing
the president of the united states takes
pleasure in presenting the bronze star
medal to petty officer third class
philip francis tourney united states
navy for service as set forth in the
following citation
for heroic achievements in connection
with the unprovoked and unexpected armed
attack on uss liberty agtr 5 in the
eastern mediterranean on 8 june 1967.
during the early afternoon hours uss
liberty while engaged in peaceful
operations in international waters was
attacked without any warning by jet
fighter aircraft and three motor torpedo
boats
the liberty was subjected to intense
incendiary machine gun and rocket fire
and was placed in extreme jeopardy by a
torpedo hit below the water line on the
starboard side in the vicinity of the
research compartment
severe structural damage and extensive
personnel casualties were incurred
petty officer terney serving as
assistant on scene leader in the ford
repair party first assisted in
organizing the evacuation of wounded
personnel from the exposed weather decks
with complete disregard for his own
personal safety he continued to
furiously expose himself to intense
rocket and machine gun fire to move a
fire fighting team to the bridge
he then returned to the forward weather
decks to ensure that no more wounded
were still exposed before going below to
maintain damage control conditions of
compartments below the water line
he remained below decks during the
torpedo attack and immediately afterward
assisted and directed emergency repairs
to minimize further flooding and damage
his aggressiveness and coolness under
fire was exceptionally inspirational
leadership in an hour of awesome peril
petty officer attorneys initiative and
courageous actions were in keeping with
the highest traditions of the united
states naval service
petty officer attorney
is authorized to wear the combat v
distinguishing device
[Music]
and that
citation reflects an obviously intense
and dire situation for a u.s naval ship
the uss liberty during a vicious and
determined attack
what the citation does not mention
is the
state or the enemy force that is
conducting the attack
and that is because the attack
was conducted by our ally by the state
of israel
and this incident the attack on the uss
liberty
has been wrought with controversy as to
how and why it happened
but there can be no controversy or no
doubt
about the courage and bravery of the
sailors on the ship that day
who suffered significant casualties
but who fought to save their shipmates
and their ship
[Music]
and his honor
to have three of those sailors with us
here
to share their experiences and their
lessons learned
phil turney
larry bowen
and joe meadors
gentlemen
thank you for joining us it's an honor
to have you all out here i appreciate
you traveling and getting out here thank
you sir that's uh
about as good as it gets from
an american hero is yourself a sailor
seal
been through it
understands what battle is all about
when you have nothing to fight back back
with but only your will and
your uh guts
to stay alive
is uh
inspirational for all the crew
it was all hands on deck
regrettably
many of our shipmates lost their lives
or so severely wounded
they had to be evacuated the next day
and we didn't get any help from our
government
during the attack after the attack 18
hours later
we say uh a cruiser or a destroyer
maddox come aboard not the maddox but
the uh
mat yeah massey
come alongside in the u.s says davis and
that was it and
those guys come aboard our ship
on whale boats and uh
they were actually crying
to see the devastation of what they did
to us
chocola there was over 850 cannon rocket
holes in our ship
over 5 000 armor-piercing bullets on our
ship
they dropped napalm on the bridge of the
ship trying to burn us to pieces
they shot our life rafts off
out we only had three left
they shot them out of the water to
ensure no more survivors
they sent troop
carrying helicopters
to finish us off
and for some reason they didn't do it i
guess they got the word it hit the gigs
up
uh and so we'll just call it a mistaken
identity and that's what
everybody says there's a mistake oh
we're so sorry
we say no to that
and
it was a deliberate premated attack
premeditated attack
by
the people of uh the johnson
administration
and
the
escola i believe his name was
the ambassador i mean the
premier for president of uh
israel of that time
a small cabal of people
did so much damage not only to us and
our dead shipmates but to america this
is just not our problem it's america's
problem and americans like you
this good gentleman over here and your
whole staff
are bringing it to light and god bless
you for that and it means the world to
me and i know it does my shipmates
it's very respectful and very honorable
you sir thank you
oh man um
it's just the the story is harrowing to
hear and and you know what one of the
things i want to go over today is the
account that you've written
of what you went through um before we
get to that just to get a little
background on on all of you um just if
maybe you could introduce yourselves
where you came from maybe a quick note
on how you ended up in the navy i mean
this is 1967 how you ended up in the
navy and really what your job was when
you were on the liberty let's let let's
start with you joe okay well joe no
larry oh sorry let's start with you
larry hi yeah i'm uh larry bowen i'm the
current uh liberty veterans association
president
um
in 1965
during the the height of the vietnam war
um i got drafted
and
i didn't want to be boots on the ground
over in vietnam so i went and talked
with a navy recruiter
and he says go take the army physical
and then we'll put you in the navy
i was 19 years old i didn't know if i
could trust him or not but um you know i
went i took the physical i passed
and by the end of march i was a
active duty navy going to great lakes
naval training center for boot camp
um
i um
i became a
cryptologic technician or communications
technician shortly thereafter boot camp
went to a school down in pensacola
florida
and um
got my first assignment
to uh bermerhaven germany
and i thought this was a great tour i
just you know
can't beat this and
four months later
i get orders to the uss liberty
so this was my my third cruise that i
was on uh
when when we were reassigned to the
mediterranean for the uh six day war
and and the the mission of the liberty
it's an interesting mission it was
really just
collection of radio traffic from all
over
all over whoever you were near right
right and am i correct in saying that
there was literally no weapons on the
liberty
do they have any weapons at all we had
four 50 caliber machine guns
two forward two aft
and
then we had small arms
which
phil and uh
rick amadi were uh were trying to get
into when we thought we were going to
have to repel borders
but the uh
the gun locker was was secured and they
were using they didn't have a key
so they were trying to break break the
lock with a sledgehammer so that they
could get in and get small arms out in
case we you know case those um
helicopters with the troops on board
tried to board us
and like phil said the
for whatever reason they they stopped
and
you know asked whether or not we had any
casualties and whether or not they could
help us
um
and uh the skipper told them basically
we don't need your help
um
not in
not in those terms but uh
you know he made it very clear that uh
we didn't want him yeah
phil how did you end up in the navy
uh that's a good question i i wasn't i
wasn't good in school
uh i dropped out of school in the
seventh grade
i went to work for my dad where are you
where'd you grow up
i grew up in denver colorado now i live
on the western slope of colorado i got a
40-acre ranch there me and my bride and
lisa sitting over there wonderful lady
love her a lot
we've raised our kids but getting back
to the navy i went to boot camp and i
was
the most thrilled
person you could ever imagine
because i was 17 years old i just turned
17 and joined and luckily i passed the
test but
uh
i mean
really i was
not very smart bookwise
and all of a sudden i get awarded to be
uh
educational petty officer
i said
how did i get this
and uh
my peers took it good that
we we got along and
i'll be darn if i wasn't voted uh
outstanding recruit of my of my troop
and uh
that was done by my peers i'll never
forget that as a bunch of good guys and
they're as old as i am now
40.
what year was that what year did you
join 64.
1964. okay and what was your job
uh
my my first job was uh being a
boilerman
and machinist mate i was on different
ships the uss monica uss holley
hallelujah
that i went overseas with the vietnam we
unload ammo to
constellation other ships and
we would also pick up
uh
bodies
uh that were flown
uh
to one part of the other and we take
them back to subway bay because we had
coolers for the ammo and stuff
and that was basically our deal for a
couple of years and then i got
transferred to liberty i said oh god
this has got to be great and what a good
ship though beautiful ship good people
enjoyable
good skippers
i can't say enough about the about the
uss liberty you're right it was a
avamor said it was like a giant lobster
out in the sea nobody could misidentify
that ship
so
that's pretty much uh my neville career
up to uh the attack
then i got transferred to uss maddox
telephone
so
it's been an interesting ride
uh joe how did you end up in the navy in
1966 i was in my second year of college
didn't know what i wanted to do in my
life you know i didn't wasn't ready for
graduation or anything like that
and
i didn't want to
be in the army and go to vietnam live in
a foxhole for my
four years so i decided to join the navy
instead
so i went and joined and then i went
home and told my mom what i did
and she about
had a fit
but
in hindsight she told me it was probably
the best
idea that i had the best thing i ever
did went to boot camp in great lakes and
i got assigned to a
to the drill team
which was fortunate for me it was under
number 912
fortunate for me
and the rest of the guys because i don't
think i did more than 100 push-ups
during my time in in boot camp
and what would you what'd you rate well
i was a signalman i went from boot camp
to a class a
uh signalman school in newport rhode
island
and then graduated from that and went to
the liberty and i never could figure out
why
since the liberty steamed independently
in my rate i
had flashing light and semaphore between
ships what was i doing there who are you
going to talk to yeah
that's an interesting thing about the
liberty because of its mission it would
just go out by itself like the normal
navy ships they go out in a in a group
in a in a carrier battle group or an
amphibious ready group where there's
multiple ships but you guys on the
liberty you would just kind of sail
around by yourselves
exactly and that's because of the
mission
with uh
if we were in a group
their communications would interfere
with our ability to collect
communications that that we were trying
to collect
so
it was by design that we would go
independently
typically off the west coast of africa
in fact our first port
on that last cruise was we pulled into
abajan
and it was in may of 1967
when we got orders to go to rotospain to
pick up supplies and some additional
people and we were going to the eastern
med
couldn't tell our folks or anything you
know they said hey this is so
hush-hush
um
and at that time i don't know that any
of us knew what was going on in the
middle east
but yeah that's a good point i know i
when i first got in the navy and i did a
couple deployments as a seal on a ship i
mean there was no internet so you really
were isolated in terms of what was going
on in the world
so
what was going on in the world at that
time was that the the
the israeli
six day war was happening um
this is a war that took place from the
5th of june to the 10th of june it was
israeli it was israel versus
a bunch of arab countries egypt syria
jordan
iraq saudi arabia
little elements of lebanon in there
and the israel israel had initiated and
there was a bunch of things that led up
to this but is israel had initiated
the war with air strikes
on egyptian and and syrian airfields
they'd they'd pretty much wiped out the
egyptian air force
on the 6th of june there was ground
fighting that was taking place as the
israeli
military pushed into the sinai peninsula
on the 7th of june they pushed even
further into the sinai
the the israeli navy was
kind of probing the egyptian navy
um
there was israeli missile boats missile
ships that were out there that engaged
egyptian shore batteries so this is a
even though it's a short war there's a
lot happening in a pretty small area as
well
um the jordanians attacked and and
sent a lot of artillery into jerusalem
um
[Music]
by the seventh though i mean israeli and
this was just a couple days into it is
israel had
gotten control over much of the west
bank
8th of june these these things are
continuing to happen so i just wanted to
kind of give some background as to what
was happening when
this event took place for you guys
so
i was just talking about june 8th you
know this is when these attacks are just
continuing this is in the midst of this
war
um and and it even though like i said
it's short but there's a lot of a lot of
fighting going on there's 20 000 arab
troops were killed in this short period
of time israel lost
under a thousand but that's you know
still significant
so in the midst of all of that um
this attack on your ship happens and
phil you you've got some personal
accounts that you've written out and
these are just to me
a great way of tracing
how this how this went down from your
perspective phil and then you know uh
larry and joe you guys can give some
input as well but i just want to read
some of these accounts because
you know i always think when i write
things down they come across a little
bit clearer it solidifies my memories so
here's what you said about the first day
and how this whole thing kicked off phil
you say this my job on the morning of
june 8th was sound and security
i would make the rounds to ensure that
everything on my checklist was in good
condition that the ship was watertight
and ship shape as i reported hourly to
the bridge
i did not see the first overflights by
israeli aircraft but the other guys told
me about them we assumed that they were
our friends and knowing that they were
merely confirming that we were an
american ship caused our moods to
further lighten
after lunch a general quarters drill was
conducted right after that i had to
accompany another engineer to the
starboard gun mount on the four castle
on the folk sauce did i just say that
you just busted a damn navy guy totally
messing that one up edit that out uh to
fix the phone located there
david skolak am i saying that right yes
david skolak was the other sailor i went
with and after i explained to him what
needed to be done his response was no no
problem tony i'll get working on her
this was about five minutes before the
attack at two o'clock p.m
as we stood there we discussed the fact
that this would be the worst possible
place to be in the event of an attack on
the ship
because the gun tub and the guy manning
it would be taken out taken out as the
first priority i said goodbye to skolak
and the gunner and made my way down the
ladder to the main deck and my
workstation in the ship fitter's shop
as i opened the hatch to go inside i
heard an order over the pa to test the
motor whale boat just moments later i
heard a huge explosion right next to the
hatch
i had just closed my immediate thought
was that the test had gone wrong and the
motor whale boat had blown up
so that's how this thing kicks off i
mean it was it was a normal day were you
guys
were you guys able to were you guys
tracking the war as it was happening
were you guys could you hear explosions
could you were you guys seeing fighting
taking place were you seeing tracers in
the sky at night and that kind of thing
no we uh we saw uh smoke from the uh el
arish area where they were
uh attacking the egyptian forces but we
didn't hear anything
and no tracers
did you guys feel
safe and secure out there
i did yeah yeah really yeah absolutely i
mean who was gonna who's gonna attack a
flagged american ship
we thought if anybody was going to get
it should be
the arabs
besides we were told that we'd have an
air cover in 30 minutes if we were ever
attacked
[Music]
the anything else that you remember
about the day before it kicked off
um
that morning
i was setting a position down in radio
research one i was a intercept operator
and
i had picked up some traffic that
was actually part of the the ground
forces communicating
back on
tel aviv
and
my buddy bob eisenberg who was working
in the processing and reporting center
when we went to
chow together at lunchtime
and he told me that
they were planning a big attack
and and that
you know it was a
prolonged kind of thing where they had
you know three different
uh
prongs to this attack
um
the jets strafing the napalm and the
torpedo boats
but what bob
didn't tell me was who the target was
apparently
they didn't
spell that out in their communications
but
that was before we had our
our practice general quarters drill so i
don't know if
if maybe commander lewis
had
sent word up to the skipper that uh
hey there's
things are going to intensify here maybe
we ought to do a drill
but
there were certainly indications in the
comms
that uh
something big was going to happen
and unfortunately you know we didn't
know that it was us that they were
targeting
um
because during the morning these
overflights that occurred and they
started early in the morning i bet we
had at least four or five overflights by
israeli aircraft and we would send our
photo recon team up to the bridge to
take photographs
and
and we knew i mean you could see the
star david on the on the aircraft
so
in my mind i felt pretty secure that uh
our ally was gonna cover us and not not
be the ones that was gonna do the
attacking
and um
joe anything else on that yeah there's a
signalman i was up on the top deck that
was it was an open deck
just has rails around it not uh
not the uh
steel pliers steel uh
sightings around and around the deck and
uh i could see all of the reconnaissance
aircraft come
and circle us in the morning
and then
i served quartermaster watches
which i didn't like but
what's a guy to do
and so i was down in the pilot house and
uh
larry and lloyd painter was the
officer of the deck and he was a junior
officer of the deck i believe and he was
watching the radar
surface search radar and he spotted the
aircraft coming up
our starboard side
very low to the deck because you know we
didn't have any air search it was just
surface search
so they got slowly or quickly
up our starboard side turned immediately
left and then left again when they got
straight ahead of us and then started
the attack
the israelis claimed that they they
conducted a series of low and slow
identification runs and i don't think
anybody would believe that
a screaming jet would uh
nobody could see it nobody could hear it
on those those identification runs
so they've they've lied about it since
the outset
all right
um
let's pick up phil with your account
after you hear this explosion so you say
not realizing that a rocket had just
exploded directly outside the hatch i
grabbed the handle and opened it once
more to go out and investigate the
trouble i just barely put one foot
outside when i felt myself grabbed by
the shirt collar and violently jerked
back inside
i turned and saw it was first class
petty officer dale niece who ordered me
to get back we're under attack
the general quarters alarm was then
sounded and i made my way to my duty
station which was
which as one deck which was one deck
above the mess
after going down the ladder i slipped
and fell and found myself under
trampling feet of sailors as they made
their way to their stations i rolled
over to my right side to get out of the
way got on my feet and joined the
stampede to get to my station as well i
got into battle dress and got my gear
ready chief thompson was the on-scene
leader as soon as i arrived he said he'd
been hit
and i was leaving and he was leaving to
get medical care since i was
assistant on scene leader this man i was
in charge it's all yours now attorney
he said as he made his way down the
passage i responded back hey thanks a
lot chief
although i was not that thrilled about
this ad hoc promotion
so it's just for people that haven't
been in the navy tell us about general
quarters what's going on
right uh general porter's is uh
something
we did aboard that ship constantly even
uh i got on i got a board delivery when
it uh it was just uh commissioned and it
made one cruise and i stayed on it for
the for the rest i'm until the last one
but
every captain i served under and there
was only two
uh mcgonagall was uh
very strict about damage control
cleanliness
he evaluated everything you did
and
i think that really really set us up to
be
at least to try to be able to to save
our ship and save our shipmates but the
training we received
uh
with the good graces of god
uh we were able to
to keep the ship afloat and it just
wasn't us you know it was uh a higher
power that that saved us nobody else
came to help us
but the good lord and i believe that now
and i always will i believed it then you
know interesting jackal you know i
thought when the uh
attack started
and we didn't get any help
i thought well okay this is world war
iii and these guys got better things to
do than screw with us
uh the american government you know
because they're doing their own thing
that's what i really thought
because they wouldn't leave us out there
alone that we would promise help
and i'll be darn uh yeah uh
no help came we were out there alone by
ourselves no armament our ship was
burning up people all over the deck
on on
sleeping
trying to get into racks or whatever
they could just to
stay alive it was uh
it was uh i can't say
it was real chaos it was organized chaos
just do your job and don't do anything
else but do your job what was your job
during general quarters
damage control so you were fighting so
did you take over for you were the
damage control senior guy at this point
at that report part yes was it for that
specific part of the ship or was it for
the
okay for that part of the ship
the other
damage control was uh
james smith
and he was fighting fires and and doing
all i could in fact
that's when uh spicer got killed he was
a postal clerk he was manning a hose
that was his general quarters drills and
his station
to uh fight fires and smitty just
got through the hatch and then spicer
was hit
i might also add that smitty's uh and i
made third class together
e fours and uh he stayed in for 27 years
and he come out a lieutenant commander
yeah he was on a lot of different shifts
smitty's a great guy he's a great hero
all these guys are heroes they're my
uh
my alter ego i respect these guys
because they help
save everybody's lives including mine
without these people i wouldn't be alive
today
joe what did you have to do during
general quarters general quarters as a
signalman my job was look out and look
for ships to communicate with ha haha
and so when when the attack started
um
mama didn't raise no fools and that
signal bridge was totally totally open
so i stayed down in the pilot house
where that was my uh
my work station basically is in the
pilot house
and uh occasionally
i would look out on the port wing of the
bridge and look up and make sure the
flag was flying
did that a couple times and then i
noticed it wasn't flying so frank brown
and i frank was uh killed while he was
on the helm frank brown and i took
holiday colors and ran it up on number
four port highland and i was up flying
during the complete torpedo attack and
holiday colors is
an even bigger flag than normal the
biggest flag we have
seven by 13.
is that cracked yellow that's something
like that yeah seven by 13 feet
what about you larry where'd you go once
general quarters kicked off
the uh
like i said i had a day watch that day
so i was down on radio research one when
they sounded general quarters
i move up one deck to
another position doing the same job with
a cadre of other cts
one of like i was in our brancher
there's a t brancher in there um we had
an o branch what's the r branch t branch
o branch okay our brancher was a radial
men okay t brancher were were the the
technical electronic skies
we had a maintenance guy in there we
also had uh
an eye brancher which is a linguist
and so we we took positions
one deck above where the torpedo hit
um
and
when when the torpedo entered
we all got blown to the overhead
got concussions that's probably when i
got my shrapnel wounds
um
and
you know it wasn't until
right after that that we were able to go
out and start opening up the hatch and
getting people out from the flooded
compartment below
but uh
when when phil mentioned that we had
this you know 29 by 39 foot of hole in
the starboard side
that killed
25 of our
crew members that were down in the
research spaces
um
and
you know one of our primary concerns was
getting anyone who's still alive getting
them out of there and getting them up to
safety
so
as soon as we got
the hatch open and people started coming
out of the flooded compartment
i had a secondary job of going to the
the front door to our compartmented
spaces and handing out life jackets to
everybody
so that
if we had to abandon ship at least
everybody would have a life preserver
and that was before we ended up
at the end after everybody got out of
the earth we thought everybody had
gotten out of there
we dogged on the hatch and had to close
up the area
secure it
going back to this account
from phil once again
i started my new duties
by determining whether all damage
control personnel were accounted for but
found that several were still missing
which was not surprising considering the
circumstances the torrent of explosions
i was hearing above and all around me
had something to do with that and the
holes that begin appearing everywhere
around us from the rocket and cannon
fire were further evidence of the
intensity of the attack
in the middle of the this onslaught i
caught a piece of shrapnel four inches
long in my right arm just above the
elbow
i pulled it out threw it on the deck and
moved everyone in my department to the
main deck
once there
i went to the same gun tub that i had
visited earlier
but only saw a pile of human remains
blood hunks of human flesh body parts
and fragments of bone
rick a medi am i saying that right
rick omedy was there with me
and we knew there was no life to be
saved so we moved on throughout this
time machine gun bullets and rocket fire
were raining down on us as we crouch
down behind various structures leaping
from one position to another
so this is i mean there's just this this
entire ship is just getting raked with
machine gun fire with rockets with with
bullets
um these bullets you're talking about
they're they're penetrating the skin of
the ship and just going through creating
holes immediately
armor-piercing bullets you're exactly
right jacqueline it was uh
it was an attack
that
there was no mercy
there was no uh
explanation in our mind because we
didn't know really who was doing it they
were doing it with
unmarked jet aircraft until we saw the
torpedo boats
and they had to star david i said oh god
they're here to help us a little bit you
know they've fired five torpedoes at us
five torpedoes and only one of them hit
and it happened to hit an i-beam
where we didn't take the full explosion
it was more of an outward deal but as
larry was saying
25 of america's
most intelligent secret personnel
in the world all of them top secret
were instantly blown to bits and uh
it's just something you can't describe
to see your own shipmates like that
and you know they're down there
the ones that got killed on deck we
already put them in body bags
and the ones that were clinging to life
uh doc kiefer took care of them i i
helped in operations uh
all these other guys did what they could
to help people it was a unified ship and
it was two different crews aboard that
ship the spooks
and us
so we were the idiots and these were the
smart guys it was too bad i i mean that
with all uh due respect
uh believe me all due respect but these
guys here took the brunt of the damage
and you know what jackal they didn't
they didn't leave their duty stations
they could have run out of there
but they stayed there
doing their duty and gave their lives
for it
and it was uh
inspirational
you just
you think about that and then
when the torpedo hit the the torpedo gun
boats
would come up alongside of us in fire at
our fire
firefighters stretcher bearers anybody
on deck
they were
that close shooting us
you know what i mean out of us
and it uh
it never occurred to me
as i've said many times that
how another
country or human being could do that to
their own supposedly friends
and get by with it
and then come back and say have you
casualties have you had any casualties
flood all over the decks
uh commander castle was in one of the
israeli helicopters he was a at the
shade there in israel
and he dropped
a card with his name on it and on the
back and says have you casualties
and i thought to myself my god how could
this i mean the guy's got to be able to
see
and
it just
everybody was astounded by that the
captain told to
get the helicopter held the hell away
from my ship get it out of here now
and they did and uh we were all alone
our country but promises help
we expected help the jet aircraft were
called back by washington
mcnamara and lbj and all his cronies uh
uh including uh
admiral uh mccain he was a
commanding
uh officer of european forces
europe and uh he was a huge part of the
cover-up
the board of enquirer only went seven
days
seven days it was wrapped up it was all
pre-predetermined what the outcome is
going to be mistaken identity they say
they paid six million or 10 million or
whatever and the crew was compensated
they compensated most of the crew 200
bucks
for their their clothes or maybe their
whatever but
the average was 200 bucks the most
seriously guys that got wounded they
deserved every penny they got
but it wasn't nothing like they said it
was and it was our money they were given
right back to us
so
israel never put out a dime the united
states paid for it all
and they sold our ship for a measly a
couple hundred thousand dollars they cut
up the razor blades
to make sure the evidence was gone but
they did they didn't count on us for 55
years telling you guys
hey you're you're lying to the american
public and you're not going to get by
with it that's why we're here now
america is too great
it's too great of a country
served
as you well know you
you've been there you know what it's all
about
and uh you didn't get
no nobody turned their back on you
because you had backup your own men and
you know
to the last man
it's it's not over till it's over
but it was like that was way with us
it's not over till it's over we're still
alive the shift didn't roll over
and uh
the next day they got there like i say
massey and the davis these guys aboard
the ship just in tears
it was uh
they hated to see their own
shipmates
get get torn apart like that with no
help
coming to find out you know uh
i think the navy did try to help us but
the government the higher-ups would
wouldn't wouldn't come to our aid and uh
it's pretty sad there's one pilot he's
in this film by the way i wanted to give
you this jocko i i think you've seen
this haven't you i have not seen that no
okay this is a sacrificing liberty
uh go to sacrifice and liberty dot com
sacrificial liberty dot com this is a a
four-part series it is one of the best
series that's ever been done
and
truthful it's all about many survivors
in this film telling you the truth and
it's my great honor and pleasure to give
this to you and i hope you you watch it
and spread the word jocko thank you
thank you
um
one one thing that should be noted about
the 25 men killed by the torpedo is that
they probably would have survived the
attack if lbj hadn't recalled the
aircraft that aircraft were already in
in flight
probably halfway to the liberty and
would have driven off the the torpedo
attack if they had been allowed to
continue
um
just to give people some more
some more context as to what was
actually happening for you guys uh
your account phil as this is taking
place
you say this dead bodies were littered
everywhere
but there were also wounded bodies that
we knew had to be found and saved if
possible between volleys of bullets and
rockets we darted out from safe cover
grabbed the wounded men one at a time
dragged them across the deck and
assisted them down the hatch others from
down below took them from there
and moved them to the mess halls where
they could be treated it took us at
least 15 minutes to clear the decks of
those who were still alive and could be
saved about 25 men all together
one of the worst cases i saw was time
tom riley a boson's mate who was on his
back and bleeding from multiple wounds
and was covered with gray paint
which might have saved his life since it
became a giant bandage
so that's the that's kind of the
situation that took place where you
where that's what you received the
bronze star for was that action going
out into into the into the fire to try
and recover wounded guys
you continue here after all the wounded
had been recovered i went to the log
room
the location of damage control
central i saw ensign john d scott there
my superior officer who is burning
documents the standard procedure in u.s
military after briefing him and
discussing the situation for a few
minutes he ordered me to return to the
deck to further assess the damages and
put out any fires that were still
burning on the way back i saw many
wounded men bloody and moaning begging
me for help
but as i had no medical training there
was not much i could do to help relieve
their pain
i got to the bridge and saw commander
mcdougall
was badly wounded in the leg but still
in command
rocket and cannon holes were everywhere
and burning napalm was dripping through
the holes into the bridge compartment
there were co2 canisters that were not
effective in fighting that kind of fire
and i requested a team with water hoses
but that didn't work either since the
fire hoses had been shot up just like
everything else
i told the captain that i would return
with some better equipment to fight the
fires and he calmly replied do what you
can sailor
he was always very professional and
stoic even under these incredibly
violent surreal circumstances
so you have
napalm dripping through the holes onto
the bridge i mean that's just
crazy to think about
it it is crazy
napalm is
is a war crime
uh dropping it on
dropping on us they wouldn't they they
want they couldn't shoot us up so they
tried to burn us up
and uh
the fires just basically burn out
because we couldn't put them out we
didn't have the equipment cot co2 was
all gone everything was
that had been utilized so it was uh
we could have gotten water
uh from the engine room they they could
have pumped this water
but there was nothing we could do with
it because the hoses were 99 percent
enroll are shot up they're all gone
and you have that in interaction with uh
the captain captain mcgonagall
he sounds like a stoic guy
one thing i remember about captain
mcgonagall and i remember distinctly is
when i was in the pilot house that's
where i stayed during 99 of the attack
and bullets were flying and napalm and
smoke and all that stuff he was very
calmly walking back and forth asking for
a cup of coffee
he says
can i have a cup of coffee please
sheesh
this is this is a just chaos it's chaos
but on our part it's organized chaos
because we were so well trained we knew
what we were supposed to do and we did
it without thinking
that's what all the training was for
you say this on on my way to the bridge
i looked at my good friend frances brown
a third class quartermaster was helping
steer the ship
he was one of my best friends on the
ship and we hung out together in better
times playing cards drinking a few beers
and joking together we just locked eyes
and communicated silently that we might
not make it through this one
i went off to find more co2 canisters
and i ran back towards the bridge
falling in the process which caused the
co2 canister to fly out of my hands and
crashed down the deck with a bang
as soon as i got up i saw that
i saw what had caused me to slip and
fall
it was blood on the deck that hadn't
been there moments before when i left
the bridge it was my friend francis
brown's blood who had caught a machine
gun bullet or a piece of shrapnel in the
back of his head and his blood was
everywhere
his eyes were closed but his face was
swelled up like a balloon
it was something that no human being
should ever have to see especially when
it's a good friend of yours
in a little while after going below deck
and seeing more scenes like that
i looked that looked like a
slaughterhouse
with a cacophony of wailing and
desperation in the background the
wounded men kept begging me to help them
and it was frustrating for me not to be
able to do that because i had to move
them from the passageways and into the
mess hall so they could get the medical
attention they needed finally the jet
attack was over
and i went back to the top deck
and then saw torbito boats coming at us
at a high rate of speed
and now i saw who it was
the star of david flags flying above
these boats was quite a surprise and at
first i assumed they were coming to our
rescue
the delusion only lasted a minute
because i then saw the splash of several
torpedoes that they dropped into the
water as they headed towards us
did you know they were torpedoes
i mean did you identify it seems like
that's such a if i would have seen
israeli boats i thought oh they're
friendly oh something just went in the
water what could that be did you
actually know they were torpedoes at
that point i i did jacob because i could
see the
trail in the water
i saw the two go aft
i don't know where the other one their
fire they've say anywhere from five to
six torpedoes the general rule is five
but
i mean five or six what difference is
make now
but uh
the two that went aft i saw those i
didn't i don't know where the other ones
they could have been
aft or forward
but i do know that one that one did hit
and uh
that's that's when uh the ship
started listening badly to the starboard
side and it just went like this well
first the ship was picked up this is
without so so before the torpedo hit
you say the four torpedoes launched
almost simultaneously they had had they
hit us the liberty would have sunk
immediately and the rest of the world
history would have been written quite
differently those four had miraculously
all missed the fifth one was fired and
it was immediately obvious that it could
not be outmaneuvered the countdown began
we were warned to prepare for a torpedo
hit and we hunkered down in torpedo
attack mode this meant bending your
knees and elbows putting your hands
against the bulkhead and relaxing your
neck
and all of that is made nearly
impossible as your thoughts of imminent
death take over your mind so there was a
time period where the fourth torpedo
launched or sorry the fourth or fifth or
whatever it was there's one that you
could tell
that it was going to hit you
could you see you could see it in the
water coming your way
no i i couldn't see it i was low dex one
deck below the main deck were they
counting it off on the 1mc or something
yes
cap said uh
prepare for torpedo hit starboard side
and
then we knew
it's just a matter of time and it hit
and i was thinking to myself
if this ship goes down i'm going to go
down with it because i'm not going to
get in the water and try to
stay alive and let them
guys shoot me in the water i'd rather go
down with the ship and that was my
intention i was going down
but the ship just
you just were actually stopped listing
um
how what are you thinking at larry as
this as you're hearing the countdown
come starboard side
that's got to be absolutely horrifying
it was and we were
internal to the ship
so i mean we had no place to run we were
had been sitting our
our general quarters positions doing our
job when he said prepare for torpedo
attack
and we got off our position
got ourselves up against the bulkhead
and squatted down and just braced
yourself
but you know you're
not you're never really prepared for
something like that
um
you just you don't know
whether or not it's going to hit
right where you're at or somewhere else
we were above the water line
but
we were right against the bulkhead that
separated our calm spaces and our pnr
spaces which is
the area that the torpedo came into
so
the
explosion itself was deafening for us
and um
you know like i said we got blown to the
overhead got concussions and probably
the shrapnel wounds that we've received
after that
um
but you immediately scramble to your
feet
to try and
help your fellow shipmates that are down
below
we didn't know how badly
the the torpedo damaged that area but
when we opened up the hatch we could
tell you know i mean the water was
rising and and people were scrambling to
try and get up the ladder so that they
could get out
um but um
yeah it's
it was nerve-racking absolutely
nerve-racking
uh
to say that we weren't scared to death i
think would be an understatement
joe
when you heard brace for torpedo impact
where were you what were you thinking i
was on the port wing of the bridge
looking up to make sure the flag was
flying
and uh when i heard that
brace for torpedo attack i just hit the
deck
and
you know not knowing what a torpedo
would do
i just felt it hit and i was lifted off
the deck just an instant
phil you say in the account when the
explosion came it was literally
deafening
i'd been directly above the point where
it hit only about eight feet away and
the explosive percussion blew out my
eardrums an injury that never completely
heals
we were all instantly airborne because
the ship itself was picked up out of the
water and then it came back down and
bounced back up and down a few more
times nearly capsizing in the process
the new moaning and groaning was not
coming from the wounded men but was now
coming from the wounded ship as the rush
of sea water flooded into the ship
since the ship itself did not blow up
that meant the torpedo did not hit the
engine room because that cold sea water
hitting the boilers would have caused
the ship to be cut in half and both
halves would have gone to the bottom
within minutes
and since scott instructed me to
determine where the torpedo had hit
so with rick omedy at my side we went
down to the communication spaces where
the spooks worked
i banged on the steel door with my fire
axe since i did not have a code to open
it and the voice told me that i was not
authorized to enter the spaces
rick and i told whoever was on the other
side to go to hell saying that we were
authorized to go wherever we had to to
keep the ship afloat
i told the person on the other side that
if they did not open the door i would
beat it off its hinges with my axe
that's a crazy story so these guys
freaking the ship got hit with a torpedo
and you go open up this damn door and
they go hey you're not authorized yeah
it was it was crazy it was really crazy
and
uh
when we got down there
we went to
the hatch that
he closed
to make sure everything was watertight
and everything and
i grabbed the hatch it had two different
hatches a big one and then a small
scuttle hatch i opened it up very slowly
and i could hear air coming out so i
knew it wasn't water
and i'll be darned for two or three
other guys were out there banging and
trying to get out and they they came out
and uh what a beautiful sight to see
them alive
yeah you say suddenly the door opened i
went to scuttle the hatch to the scuttle
hatch and turned it then opened it very
slowly i heard air escaping in our
direction which meant that the
compartment was not completely filled
already but was filling
just as i opened it i heard frantic
banging on the other side so i turned
the wheel as fast as i could and
sergeant bruce lockwood united states
marine corps came scrambling out while
pulling another sailor of safety as well
umedy and i grabbed the two and yanked
them out of the hole ensign scott came
up carrying a battle lantern and ordered
me to give
him my belt
i did as he asked and then he used it to
lower the lantern into the water to look
and check for any more signs of life
after a few moments we looked at each
other
and he asked
what i thought
sir i said
i think we'd better seal her up
so that's one of those moments where
um you know as a leader
you got to make a the hardest decision
that a person could have to make
which is we don't know who else is down
below we know that this this is filling
up with water and when we seal this
hatch we're sealing their fate but in
order to save the ship
that's the decision that you have to
make
absolutely it was a very difficult
decision but it was
pretty instantaneous
as soon as that decision was made i mean
it was done
but we would periodically go back and
check listen
but it was old it was all over those
guys didn't have a chance uh
it was well lucky enough he got out and
many more but
uh
it was just
i mean uh to think about
25 of your shipmates down there and i
didn't know how many got killed at that
time down there
but to think that they they went through
that and
what we went through above deck they
didn't know what was going on below deck
they they didn't have a clue
but uh
like i said earlier these guys
they didn't abandon their duty stations
and what kind of courage does that take
to stay the low decks
in the ct spaces on the starboard side
and uh
take what what they're gonna get and uh
they did brave brave wonderful men
that's why we're here
there are dead shipmates they can't
speak
but we can speak for him and we've been
doing that forever
trying to get the truth out
but our government
wants it sealed to stay sealed and so
does israel now again it's not
it's not against the jews it's not
against
americans they just got fed lies and
we're here to say hey we're eyewitnesses
are you going to believe the israeli
version
the
board of enquirer version which is a
total bs
are you going to believe eyewitnesses
like us
now i think the american public is smart
enough especially with what's going on
in the world now to see that uh
how powerful a government can be if they
want to silence
you it's gotten so bad that the us navy
curator and the u.s navy historian wrote
the
official government
version of the attack and he based it
entirely on the israeli version
wow
well more people are going to hurt hear
this version than that version how you
like that god
going back to the account now the
torpedo boats began firing at us with
machine guns shooting anything that
moved including firefighters and
stretcher bearers
one of the guys i was pulling to safety
got hit right above the knee with a 50
caliber slug causing an explosion of
blood and bone i took off my shirt and
tied the sleeves around the top of his
leg as tight as i could stop the
bleeding we got him down to the mess
decks and untied the tourniquet for just
a few seconds so that they wouldn't be
forced to amputate the leg later then we
re-tied it before leaving the area amedy
and i went back up to the main deck and
saw that the gunners on the torpedo
boats were now shooting at the ship on
the water line
aiming in the direction of the boilers
and from merely 35 yards away clearly
they were trying now to blow up the ship
by hitting the boilers and causing a
huge explosion that their last torpedo
had failed to accomplish
throughout the course of the torpedo
boat attack they circled the ship like
vultures at as close as a hundred feet
to suggest that they might have missed
the huge lettering on both sides of the
bow in ten foot high letters as well as
the uss liberty lettering on the stern
seems impossible
and you're sitting there seeing these
guys just lay into you with 50 caliber
machine guns from 100 yards away yes sir
and nothing to fight back with
but our will and
and uh wits and the
the pleasure of taking another breath
is what kept us all going and uh
pretty fortunate to be here jocko
i saw one of the torpedo boats a lot
closer than a hundred yards
one of them i was on the port winglet
bridge is i spent a lot of time out
there making sure the flag was flying
and
i saw one of the torpedo boats sail
very slowly up our port support side i
didn't see him fire anything
but i did notice the the uh crew on the
uh on the torpedo boat
motion up to the uh signal bridge up to
that area so they can see the flag and
then they just
sail off and continue to attack
how much time had passed between the
initial
strafing runs from the aircraft to the
attack and is this an hour's gone by two
hours approximately two hours some
people say more some people probably
save less
but to do that type of damage and
in a few moments like the israelis said
it just took a little while
they only said they had only three
aircraft that attacked us and there was
probably 20 aircraft
that attacked us to do that kind of
damaging that shorter time it's just uh
when you think back
three airplanes can't carry the
munitions it would take to put over 850
cannon rocket holes in this ship drop
napalm on us and
it just it doesn't make sense
so as all this is going on you say all
of the sounds of these machine guns and
the sheer hell taking place might have
been the reason why there was some
controversy of whether commander
mcconnell ordered all crew prepare to
abandon ship but i heard that order
probably because he felt that there was
no possibility at that point we could
save the ship
he was probably not aware yet that
nearly all the lifeboats were either
destroyed by rockets gunfire napalm that
there were only three left and i
personally put one of them into the
water as i watched all three inflate
only to see them immediately shot up two
sank but one of them was taken aboard
one of the boats as a trophy
that capped the series of horrors i
witnessed that day and told me as
clearly as anything else that the
purpose of the attack was not just to
the ship and take it out of
commission so that it could not
eavesdrop on communications but to
actually sink our ship
the act of destroying our lifeboats was
an unmistakable sign that they wanted no
survivors left to tell anyone what had
happened
lloyd painter testified about that he
witnessed the machine gunning of the
life rafts and he testified about that
during the u.s navy court of inquiry but
if you get a copy of the court of
inquiry his testimony has been removed
not redacted removed
from the record
what are you thinking when you hear
abandoned ship what are you thinking
about larry
did you hear that call i did i was um
had a secondary
duty station at that point our uh
our fantail phone talker had taken
a rocket hit
was seriously wounded and he was down in
the dispensary
i was back on the fan tail
as a as phone talker i had a first class
petty officer jeff carpenter
saw me getting some fresh air
while
huddled behind a a winch
and uh he said bowen go back and be the
phone talker
and
i saw the the torpedo boats
when i heard the skipper say you know
prepare to abandon ship
i was i was thinking to myself you know
i mean this
this is it you know i mean they're
they're right there
they can shoot every one of us in the
water
you're trying to decide whether or not
you
you've got a chance of
jumping overboard and swimming for or
going down with a ship like phil talked
about and of course i stood my ground
and
waited
but that was about the same time that i
saw
unidentified aircrafts approaching from
the starboard side
and it was
a helicopter
and they were
coming out at that point
to find out whether or not we had any
casualties whether or not they could
provide any kind of assistance
and
so
obviously we didn't have to abandon ship
but um
you know
you're scared to death again you don't
know uh
you've got nowhere to run
i mean we were like
ducks in a barrel
and uh
they just opened fire and
you know we we had no no way to defend
ourselves
and and you guys
mentioned this already but just to just
to reiterate
there was some heroic activity took
place for people for some of your
shipmates to get
onto the deck of the ship and string up
a long wire antenna and send out an sos
message and that actually made it to
six fleet which was you know like i
talked earlier about big groups of ships
and you guys traveled solo but normally
the us navy travels in big groups of
ships so that was the sixth fleet is one
of these big groups of ships um had an
aircraft carrier and whatnot and they
actually received the sos that you guys
were in trouble under attack
and and talk me through about what you
know about how that how the response
the rescue response
got shut down
a very good question uh
we didn't learn for
quite quite a while exactly why and what
for
but
it it just seemed like
uh
nobody really cared about us you know
nobody including the president he's the
one that god said to this mess lbj snake
lbj
and his minions but
i never thought i never thought
that the greatest fighting force in the
world
would leave us behind
but they didn't they they wanted to come
help us that's why captain tully got
fired they took his command away because
he immediately launched aircraft not
once but twice
and they released capitol he was someone
on
uss saratoga on the uss saratoga they
received the signal that you all were in
trouble and he said okay we got sailors
in trouble we got u.s navy ship in
trouble we're gonna go help him and he
launches aircraft to go help yes before
they even
before they even uh left the horizon of
the ship they were recalled back
thanks to lbj and mcnamara
and
i believe that we were set up from the
get-go i don't know if it was a year
before six months before or whatever
but frontline 615
uh
was all about uh
6'5
6th of june 15th i mean yeah 6th of uh
june on the 15th day the war was
supposed to start but they started early
that's why they rushed us out of
out of
abidjan to get to the area just as fast
as we could i mean that old ship was
was doing as fast he was shaking we got
they took the governors off the engines
and we were on our way flying
but
uh
everybody was apprehensive we hell we
didn't even know from the radio signals
i mean what was going on the middle east
but there was a war going on and here we
go and we look out and here we are and
sailing up and down the coast like we
usually did in africa that was our only
position in africa was just set up and
down the coast and collect
intelligence like everybody else does
but
when we got on scene and and you could
see as joe mentioned before
the black smoke coming up from uh
from the uh
attacking forces israel's
going into uh the sinai it was uh
i thought well jesus man i'd hate to be
over there i never knew it was coming to
us
and uh
we were the intended target to sink
in my view and i think a lot of other
guys do is sink it uh blame it on
nassar
and uh world war iii would have broken
out because uh the russian subs were
there ready to
ready to nuke israel
and
the our government sent
bombers
to bomb
uh
the arab states and they were recalled
within seconds of a catastrophe
of a nuclear war
yeah so i read that as well um
that we had launched
nuclear weapon armed aircraft as a
response to what was happening and then
those got recalled as well yes sir
exactly right
if you look at this tactics used by the
israelis during the attack
they started with
unmarked aircraft or they jammed our
radios on both u.s navy tactical and
international maritime distress
frequencies they used unmarked aircraft
they
used napalm to drive the ship's crew
down below decks brought in torpedo
boats to with six torpedoes total
luckily only one hit and then hilo born
assault troops
it was obvious to me and most people
that their intention was to sink the
ship and kill all any survivors
speaking of that um the the hilo born
assault troops here we go shortly after
the boats left the scene
from far off in the distance but closing
in fast came the unmistakable womp womp
sound of a very large troop carrying
helicopter approaching the ship on the
starboard side
now the 1mc system blared
all ships personnel prepare to rebel
repel borders
so now after all other weapons were
brought to bear on our ship and failed
to sinker we were about to be boarded by
marines armed with submachine guns after
the only machine guns on the ship had
been destroyed in the wave of first
attacks
even if we could get to them in time the
only other guns we had on the ship were
small arms pistols and a couple shotguns
that we might use to set up a last line
of defense ahmedi and i tried to open
the locker with our fire axes
since our master at arms who was the
only one with a key was not to be found
even after beating that lock nearly
pieces we could not break it
the commandos on board the helicopter
above appeared to be ready to repel onto
our ship ready for close quarters combat
with a bunch of defenseless draggled
sailors worn out from two hours of
sustained attacks
it would have been a turkey shoot
but we were not too about to go down
without a fight for our lives had they
proceeded they could have murdered the
entire crew and then proceeded to use
whatever explosives they had to
guarantee the ship's destruction
as the helicopter hovered overhead no
more than 75 feet away i locked eyes
with one of the marines these are
israeli marines who was sitting on the
floor of the helicopter his legs were
hanging out he had one foot on the skid
below as he waited for an order to repel
down to the ship's deck and finish us
off
as i stood on the deck of my bloody and
battered ship i thought about everything
that had happened over the course of
that afternoon about my good friends
francis brown and david skolak and all
the other men whose remains were strewn
all over the ship
the only tool i had left was my middle
finger and i used it to let him know
what i thought of him and the rest of
his team
he simply gave me a smile and returned
the gesture
and then they
they backed off right that's they they
didn't land they they flew away they
just took they just took off giaco and
it was
it was uh
a victory for us
our first victory of the whole
mess what was them not coming aboard
because they they could have easily in
fact
come back that night and got us
and
for some reason they didn't do it
because they could have gotten by with
it very easily oh okay the ship broke
apart the israelis said that
the arabs did it and uh i think we
better go get their arms i think we
better just go get them that's that was
a whole is a land grab for israel and in
a power grab for lbj to keep his war
machine going in vietnam
and it's not like you guys got help
quickly
um
you say this it's 18 hours a hell to
call it a long night is a big
understatement none of us slept for two
reasons first we were afraid of the dark
not like little kids but rather because
we knew that criminals prefer the cover
of darkness when doing their dirty work
those responsible for the previous day's
attack might return to the scene
of the crime to finish what they had
failed to do earlier
second we didn't know if the ship would
even stay together although we were not
sure of the exact size the hole in the
starboard side we knew that it was big
very big
there was a lot of work that would be
needed just to keep the ship afloat and
moving away from the danger zone and
with all the men killed or wounded only
a skeleton crew remained to do this
those of us who did survive were glad of
that of course but we all felt an
enormous amount of survivor's guilt why
me why us
we asked ourselves silently why had we
been spared while others had not
the dead included two of my good friends
francis brown who was shot in the head
with a 50 caliber machine gun round and
his brain splattered all over the bridge
and david skolak
who had who had been with just minutes
before the attack he was also caught the
machine gun fire and had been blown to
pieces too many to count
i went to the mess deck to see if i
could help with the severely wounded men
as soon as i entered the sheer mass of
human suffering moved me so much to
emotion
that my knees got weak but i dared not
let it show as i went from broken man to
broken man asking what i could do to
help him feel more comfortable
what was the total ship's crew
two thousand crew was either wounded or
dead
what were you doing throughout the night
larry
a little bit of the same that phil was
just talking about went to the mess
decks to to help relieve the corpsmen we
only had
one
ship's uh
officer you know to skip our uh oh the
doctor and the doctor had dr kiefer
and uh
and then two corpsmen a second class and
a third class petty officer so
i'm an eagle scout i had some first aid
background
uh not that it was going to do much for
some of the maimed bodies that that were
laying there in a mess decks
but like phil said you're you're there
to try and comfort them and
you know just just talk to them
uh
i was actually you know
providing
some kind of
an ointment to their wounds
um
you know the corpsman would give me
something and say go go you know wipe
this wound here or whatever um
and and so i was doing that
um
didn't get any sleep that night
and i think uh the main reason was i i
wanted to stay awake in case something
happened and that that bulkhead gave way
because we would have had to abandon
ship as quickly as we could i still had
my my life vests on
i wasn't going to give that up
but
i was i was not alone i mean there were
a lot of us walking wounded i was i was
wounded but i didn't realize
that i had the shrapnel wounds in my
thigh
because your adrenaline is pumping so so
fast
that and you're you're taking care of
others so i had blood from
trying to take care of john spicer
and uh
you know working with some of the other
wounded that my my dungarees were just
kind of blood soaked
and i didn't find out until
i don't know i guess a day or two later
when one of the
doctors from one of the other ships
was up in the dispensary and they were
you know evaluating us to determine
whether or not we had sustained any
injuries and of course i dropped trial
and he said
how'd you get those you know
scars on your leg there i had shrapnel
wounds i said i don't know i must have
been during the torpedo attack
um
but
as far as working through the night
we did whatever we could to try and you
know keep keep everyone calm it wasn't
chaotic i mean they weren't
there might have been some moaning here
and there but
it wasn't a lot of
screaming and yelling or anything like
that everybody realized that hey they're
still alive
and
we're going to get out of this
we kept thinking that we were going to
get some support but
nothing ever came
what about you joe what were you doing
throughout that night throughout that
night there's a signal when i was up on
the signal bridge
looking for uh ships
and uh thinking someone might be coming
to help you
either way
and if i saw a light
moving along in the sky i don't care how
high up it was i always had my little
all this flashing lamp
and i tried to signal it i knew it was
futile
but i had to try it because all the
other signal lights are destroyed
um
going back to the account here from you
phil as i was doing this commander
philip armstrong the ship's executive
officer called my name
i thought that his condition was
critical but he was active and alert and
seemingly in little pain he asked me for
a cigarette so i lit one and put one in
his mouth for him
he asked me many questions about the
number of dead and wounded and the
captain's condition
while i heard the agony of the men all
around us
i left him for a few minutes to try and
find anything to help comfort the men
and by the time i returned to check on
commander armstrong to my great shock
and sadness i found that he had just
died then i went to the wardroom the
mess hall for the officers
there i saw another one of my friends
glary ben gary blanchard an enlisted
seaman whose front showed no signs of
wound but he was lying in a puddle of
his own blood that seemed to be getting
bigger by the second
he asked me to remove his socks because
his feet were on fire i did as he asked
then he asked if he was going to make it
i could do no more than shake my head no
i always hated myself for not lying to
him or at least ignoring the question
and changing the subject
but i did hope that my response allowed
him
the chance to make peace with his maker
before the final curtain
these four men were among the nearly
three dozen killed that day many of whom
i'd never gotten a chance to know
i had met the ship's doctor
i'd i met the ship's only doctor there
in the wardroom
dr richard keifer am i saying that right
kiefer kiefer
he came over and began to operate on
gary however it quickly became clear
that it was too late
as soon as he opened him up
he then had to put stitches in him to
hold him together before doc moved on to
his other numerous patients
all of whom desperately needed his
attention
if anyone aboard that ship deserved the
congressional medal of honor it was doc
kiefer
as time went on
we went about our regular duties now
modified because of the precarious
condition of the ship we were still
unsure why we had been attacked and by
whom
israeli flags had been seen on at least
one boat and the helicopters but the
thought that our friend and ally would
do something so treacherous was
unthinkable but nothing was normal
anymore and that thought was the only
possible explanation
the brutality intensity and long
duration of the attack and the obvious
fact that they wanted to kill us all
and sink the ship had become quite clear
to all of us
why else would they destroy our only
means of escape by shooting up our
lifeboats
as i began to resume my regular duty
sounding security and damage control i
realized that my heroic shipmates had
saved the ship that day by remaining at
their posts while under the attack
i started making my usual rounds which
now included both bulkheads encompassing
the ct space is where the torpedo had
hit the walls made from plate steel no
more than an inch thick if that were
sweaty from the cool ocean water on the
other side i could even hear the water
sloshing around knowing that if the
bulkheads ever gave way we would all be
goners
there were cracks in the steel walls
caused by the enormous pressure being
exerted against them by the
mediterranean sea
they were ballooning outward from that
pressure and i feared that the cracks
would get larger and larger until they
finally would give way
they looked like they were alive and
breathing as they heaved in and out with
the movement of the ship and the
pressure of the water i got shivers
standing in such close proximity to them
knowing that the only thing standing
between me and my own death was a plate
of steel that was ready to come crashing
into the boiler room at any second
that thin steel wall was the only thing
keeping the sea water from flooding into
the interior of the ship and if that
happened the ship would have immediately
sunk from a huge explosion when the cold
water hit the hot boilers
so you're you're looking at the wall of
the ship
you know on the other side of this wall
and these are like interior walls that
aren't meant for the pressure of the
external sea no sir and you can see them
bowing
from the pressure they're like balloons
just bowed out
little cracks in the bottom on the sides
and water was coming through not a lot i
mean just uh sweating more or less
sweating
but we we got help finally from the us's
davis and massey and the davis food
coming aboard
and gave us great assistance and great
help in
securing the bulkheads
with uh
with the wood
and plywood
it was a knee wall
pressed up against the bulkhead
and you had to
to check it out to every every half hour
45 minutes if if i wasn't on watch my
other shipmates would go through there
and get under there like i did and
with a battlelander and look i mean i
thought to myself boy this is pretty
stupid what am i going to do if it
if it busts open now and i'm here
looking for little cracks didn't make
sense to me but i had to do it
and your boilers are still running this
whole time yes sir employers were never
taken offline one was taken offline but
we always had steam to the boilers
always at least one boiler what what
direction were you sailing in
do you even know where were you trying
to go fourth i think part of me were you
trying to get to the fleet what were you
trying to do yeah i i think once the
attack started i i think we we took a
northerly course trying to get out of
there
uh might have even been a northwesterly
course
um trying to get away from
let's just get away from that whole area
exactly
but obviously we couldn't move fast
enough to get away from
you know screaming jets and
motor torpedo boats i mean
flank speed for us was what 17 knots or
18 knots i think we did 21 knots during
the speed uh speed trial during yeah
from abidjan to rota oh okay
and so it was the uss davis and the uss
massey that that eventually showed up
were you there on this looking for him
when they showed up oh yeah i saw him
come out of the morning mist
six 16 hours later
how'd that feel
uh
pissed
like where were you
and what was the what was the look on
the faces the guys when they would they
pull just pull alongside you guys yeah
one of them well initially they sent
boats but
i think the davis actually tied up
alongside us for a while yeah
and what were those what were those
sailors they were the same they were
in damage control
and they had more equipment than we did
and uh to be quite honest they had uh
more expertise
and
they they were in shock but they
they knew what they were doing and uh
god bless them for that they helped us
out a lot but uh they
believe these guys were so good to us
and uh
it wasn't the navy's fault it was the
higher ups like i said before because
these guys
i mean they felt bad they could have
been there they could have helped us
the captain asked for uh a uh escort a
de or a destroyer
uh anything
but
you're not a warship you're an auxiliary
ship
nobody's gonna mess with you
and so they denied us even that just to
have an escort
going into a war zone
with an unarmed ship
uh
i mean it's pretty incredible that's
that's why i know that
in my heart i think my shipmates
probably agree too that
we were set up to have this exact thing
happen the only thing is
they couldn't sink us
they sure tried but they couldn't do it
and that by the grace of god we're here
right now
to be on your great show and to have
your listeners
take a look at this because we're not a
cabal we're not a conspiracy we're not
anything we're just american citizens
that served our country honorably
to tell the truth
and
we'll go that will go down that way to
the last man standing
we're not going to take this we have we
haven't taken it for so many years
joe was the first president of the lva
he was in saudi arabia he worked for
ramco and uh
he was a president long distance
remember that joke
and uh it was uh
it was pretty amazing but
i just give all the credit to the great
crew these wonderful men here and i love
them all
and i'm proud to be an american
but i got to say one thing at this point
in my life
jocko i'm not
i've always been proud of my country
not i'm not right now because i'm
ashamed of what's going on the
leadership and uh
it reminds me of uh
back in 67 the same type of leadership
council culture just didn't start with
these people it started a long time ago
in 67 they tried to cancel us out
but they couldn't do it
and i've had threats in my life
you know i've had
a lot of things happen me and my wife
were in san diego visiting
and i was in uh the lounge having a
drink with my wife right getting ready
to go go get something to eat
and this guy sat beside me and uh
he says oh you're bored of liberty and i
said uh hmm
how'd you know that and he began to tell
me the whole story and the best thing
for me to do is just shut up
i said uh what
he says listen i work for the mossad i'm
a facade agent and you better shut up my
wife was there too
and boy did she give him hell
they had to get security to to get us up
to our room
but uh i asked i asked the bartender i
said who is the guy well he's been
coming here the last couple days and he
said he was a doctor that's what he told
me too had a great big watch on i told
him get the watch out of my face are you
taking pictures of me or whatever you're
doing
and uh he says probably
but i gave you another warning and
that's when my wife chimed in and
i think she gave me more heck than i did
because she said she's a fighter too but
uh
it was uh it was amazing and how did
they find out
who
we were in san diego
either by my credit cards or phone or
something i don't know but they they
found us and gave me a stern warning
and that was uh
13 years ago when that happened
one thing should be said about the uh
six fleet personnel their radio men
didn't come out of this unscathed
because
they listened to our calls for help
after the aircraft were recalled knowing
that those aircraft were recalled
and it had to affect them
because we were still calling for help
um
i mean just just in case anyone is
anyone doesn't have the impression of
what happened on on this ship let me go
back to the account here as this as this
sort of wraps up one of your final
duties phil you say ricometti and i
found some undamaged fire hoses and
began hosing off the deck
with a suicide nozzle that sprayed water
in very concentrated high pressure
stream
it took both of us to handle this hose
because it was like a giant python and
one man could not do it alone
it was the most gruesome heartbreaking
task either of us
had ever done
because every piece of flesh was the
remains of our fellow sailors many of
whom were friends
as media and i went about this ungodly
task
tears streamed down our faces and i
prayed to god for forgiveness for how we
were forced to treat the remains of
these men
in the gun tubs we found a shoe with a
foot still in it which we put aside for
collection
many of the blood stains would not come
off even with that special hose because
the previous day's intense heat
not just baking under the sun's heat but
from the rockets and napalm that had
been dropped on the ship by the
attacking
aircraft
we found out the hard way
how hot this brutal weapon can burn
as hot as 2200 degrees fahrenheit
so
um
the davis
they also start taking some of your
wounded off right is that correct
uh i'm not very clear on that draco for
sure but i i do know that
the most seriously wounded
uh were airlifted off the ship from the
uss america
uh
and uh
the the davis and the massey
were i guess more or less there to to uh
to help us out
and but i don't think there's
any evacuees that went to the davis you
know
i went to the uh little rock
yeah that's what i thought
so they but they did start pulling the
wounded guys off
yeah yeah yep
and then
and then you guys end up um
sailing to malta that's that's the next
thing that you do i mean you get you the
ship stays underway
and again you got some good stuff in
your account i mean just that this that
trip is no easy trip because the walls
are could collapse at any moment
um and it's not the closest
oh it's not the closest spot no
where would have been the closest spot
what would uh
why'd they pick malta
hoping we'd sink
if it's further away doing four four
knots
five notch tops how many days did it
take you to get there
six or seven days yeah seven days yeah
it was uh and then uh i'm just probably
you probably already know this but that
uh admiral kid
i think that's another reason they sent
us to malta because he wanted to brief
us all
and get our account of what what went on
yeah i've got i've got your account of
how that goes down that's that's very
interesting and actually i got another
account
from ron kucal am i saying that right
yes right ron kucal and he's one of the
survivors he's actually the guy that
helped put this interview together he
did um he's got a book that's called
remember the liberty that he wrote um
and he had this to say about the events
once you guys arrived in malta he said
on arrive in malta we were headed
straight to dry dock and once we were in
it was up to the great crew at malta to
get us set up for repairs and whatever
else needed to be done what never
occurred to me was the grizzly duties
that we were that were about to be laid
squarely on our shoulders in my case as
a senior enlisted man on the crew i was
put in charge of recovery and
identification
i will admit i tried to talk my way out
of this one but i was told those were my
orders and i followed them
that hour arrived sooner than i wanted
as we made our way down to the dark hole
below
no one knew what to expect and i was
extremely apprehensive about what we
could see
for 48 years i've said little about what
i saw because i wanted to spare the
loved ones of these men
that cruelty if i could
with the writing of this book and in the
distance in years i think i can at least
say that the scene could compare to a
wrecking yard of autos
but these were human body parts strewn
everywhere carnage that escapes
description with mere words
and there were more bodies that were
down below which were brought to me to
try and identify those bodies were
wedged between steam pipes and in places
that a body wouldn't fit
if it's any consolation to the loved
ones of those men
know that they
never knew what had hit them they
couldn't have
it had to have been
instantaneous
and then as you mentioned phil once
you're in malta it's time for this
investigation this investigation is
being run by admiral isaac
kidd
actually admiral isaac kidd jr yes the
the the senior
isaac kid admiral isaac kid was
killed
in
pearl harbor yes sir
and his son
jr was commissioned 12 days after his
father was killed and he served in
europe in the pacific theaters in world
war ii and he was the guy in charge of
this liberty incident inquiry and as you
already mentioned i mean you'd think an
incident like this just to gather the
proper information would take months and
then to
go through it all would take months you
know if not years to get through it all
uh
they get this whole thing done in seven
days yes sir and you know dr kiefer
very eloquently said
why would the
united states government take on
faith
what the israelis said
when they
muzzled us eyewitnesses
never to say a word about it
or consequences could be very very very
severe
prison or worse we all know what uh
worst meant i was told that directly by
admiral kidd
that's the strange thing so admiral kidd
shows up tanks off his rank yes and
what's he a two-star at this point
uh
yeah he was a rear
admiral yeah so he so he's a two-star
animal takes off his rank and sits sits
you guys down ask you all a bunch of
questions hey did you see any markings
on the recon aircraft did you did you
see any markings on the other aircraft
did you see the torpedo boats were there
any markings on the torpedo boats did
you see the the did you see the torpedo
boats machine gunning the life rafts are
you sure the u.s flag was flying over
the ship so he's asking you all these
questions
and at the end of asking all these
he puts his stars back on
and he says okay fellas now i'm an
admiral again and i want each and every
one of you to understand something
we are talking about national security
here not your personal feelings not what
you did or did not do i could really
give a about any of that you listen
to me once because this is the only time
you're ever gonna hear it you are never
to repeat what you just told me to
anyone not your mother your father your
wife anyone including your shipmates
you are not to discuss this with anyone
and especially especially
not with the media or you will end up in
prison
or worse
you know i
i took that to heart when i first met
lisa
maybe 39 years we got married to go
got married in june
and i never told her i was in the
military at all until i read an article
by stan white
he was a master chief aboard the ship
and
it was like a
ocean of relief came out to me i i said
wow somebody else was saying something
now i can start talking little did i
know
these guys here just set up the uss
liberty veterans association which i
became a part of as soon as i found out
you guys were
were
you know getting together and
it's been a constant battle ever since
we were in the rose garden uh w.h bush
was a president
and uh we were out there for hours and
scorching heat you know how it is in d.c
what were you doing there were you
invited to be there as as vets of the
liberty to meet the president of the
united states and he stiffed us
he wouldn't talk to us
so
he sent out brent goldcroft and uh
um
what year was it that
that article came out that you said what
year did you guys start start talking
about what had actually happened when
jim anderson's book came out uh assault
on the liberty
and what year was that 79 yeah
yeah
so you guys just kept it to yourself for
whatever 12 or 13 years not saying
anything yeah who who would we talk to i
mean
everybody was uh
spread out all over the country we
didn't know uh where any of the
survivors were did you make any sense of
it in your own minds did you think
yourself well i could see why they're
trying to do this they don't want to
have you know bad relations with israel
they're trying to cover up the the the
fact that the american government was
somehow involved with this i mean what
were you thinking in your own minds i
was thinking that they'd already held an
investigation and
and uh everything was copacetic but
come to find out they have never
investigated a matter of fact the court
of inquiry was ordered by lbj to have a
finding of fact the very first one that
the attack was a case of mistaken
identity
that's what lbj said yes that's what the
ward boston said
because he was ordered he was a legal
advisor yeah i got a quote here from
award boston who's the chief legal
counsel for the u.s navy court of
inquiry and he says quote i know from
personal conversations i had with
admiral kidd president of the court inc
of inquiry that president lyndon johnson
and secretary of defense robert mcnamara
ordered him to conclude that the attack
was a case of mistaken identity despite
overwhelming evidence to the contrary
end quote
and that's the chief legal counsel
to the navy court of inquiry to the
liberty incident this isn't somebody
that's jumping in from some other you
know some other realm to try and give
his opinion
well uh
you know uh
ward boston was a
a good man a very brave man for coming
out
and setting the record straight but uh
there were there were people before him
trying to help us you know all around
but when a.j crystal wrote a book called
the liberty incident
that set him on fire because it was a
book of lies and he he couldn't take it
anymore he says i'm gonna stick up for
these guys and tell the truth what did
the what did the book the liberty
incident say it said that uh it was an
israeli talking point in the american
talking point it was a mistaken identity
we're another but a bunch of
disheartened fools
that uh have got a axe to grind our only
astro grind is to to tell the truth
that's why we're here we're not here to
to lie or fabricate or anything like
that we live through it and we don't
want anybody else to go through that
ever again
it has our government abandon them you
know
same thing in afghanistan
they left everybody there and all those
there's 13 people that got 13 american
heroes that got slaughtered for what
forgotten and uh that was us we were
forgotten it's done it's too late
larry when did you
start hearing that people were starting
to tell the truth about the situation
again it was a jiminist book assault on
the liberty
i read the book
but i was still on active duty and i
still had my top secret clearance
and so
i wasn't saying anything to anybody
and
as it turns out
after i retired from the navy in 1986
i
i went to work as a defense contractor
still supporting the national security
agency so i still needed my clearances
so i never said anything
i never really started talking about the
liberty
to my family or anyone else until i
started going through
ptsd
psychiatric you know treatments
so
i knew that there were other books out
i know that
phil had two or three books that he
wrote
the one that you referenced earlier
about
ron cookel
[Music]
phil's also
a contributor to that book and ernie
gallo is another member of the crew that
helped uh
you know with that how long did how long
were you in the navy for 21 years did
you get a purple heart for being wounded
i did and what would you tell people
when some other you know you're out
you're near jess white's for whatever
reason and you know
1975 there's
the guys were in vietnam sure some you
know guys there's some corman some
medics some pilots some aviators might
have got purple hearts some some guys
from the sea wolves or something but
there's not a lot of navy guys running
around in 1975 1980 1985 that had purple
hearts what did you say to somebody when
they said hey where'd you get that
purple heart from
i was on the uss liberty in 1967 when we
were attacked
and um
you know i got it for shrapnel wounds
um
and that was about it you know and no
one would ever pry and say
you know what the hell happened what was
going on how how'd that occur
oh i think a couple of times you know
people would try and and pry more out of
me
and um
i just wouldn't say anything i said i
just can't talk about it
and again it was because of the threat
of fines and imprisonment
if we ever spoke about it
being being a
communications technician
all of my work that i did was secret so
trying to keep a secret
wasn't wasn't something that was new to
me
um
i just suppressed it to the point that
it was building up inside me
and finally i had to go to counseling
did you how do you still have your
clearance
no when i when i retired
in 2008
i relinquished my my clearance they
didn't take it away that you you
relentlessly
i just i just decided i was 62 years old
it's it's time to uh pull the plug and
uh
as you were serving in the navy
now it's 1975 now it's 1979. now it's
1982.
and you know that
you know you know you got ordered to not
say anything
which look i mean there's things that
i've done which i'm not allowed to talk
about right you realize okay i might not
know everything about the situation but
i know i'm not allowed to talk about it
but i'm sure that there's a reason for
that that makes sense
and i get it
you know was part of you thinking
you know we this is not this this
this didn't happen the way they say it
happened this seems like they're
covering it up not for any reasons of
national security but for other reasons
yes i mean i
because i work for the national security
agency
they actually did a report in 1980
that was
classified top secret
and it was their
recap of what happened to the uss
liberty i had a copy of that report
on my desk
until i retired from the navy in in 1986
then i had to turn it back in because it
was you know
was that report accurate no
no
and
i mean there was information that i knew
should have been in there that had to
deal with communications
that that didn't reflect those
communications
and
the thing that they were trying to
report more than anything else
was a lack of communications that
occurred resulting from
this hundred mile um
free zone i guess that israel had
declared
no
no ship should enter into that hundred
mile zone
off off the coast of cyanide
and
apparently our
naval attache
in um in israel
had told them that
we don't have any navy ships there
sixth fleet confirmed that they didn't
have any any naval ships there and
that's
you know
a problem with us traveling by ourselves
that they um they didn't recognize that
we were over there or
they conveniently
forgot that we were there right but
there was communications that were
supposed to have been sent to us telling
us to move back off the coast and we
never received those communications and
so that's more about what this report
from nsa said and it didn't talk about
the other
intercepts that had you know the
aircraft talking to ground control or
talking about the target talking about
seeing the american flag
and
you know
i don't know why that didn't come out
until later but
we kept doing freedom of information act
requests trying to get
a lot of this documentation
back out in public so the truth could be
told
so joe what did you do after the
incident took place how much longer were
you in the navy for did you stay and
what did you do i got out
i was transferred off the liberty onto
the uss sylvania so
it was afs ii
fast combat stewardship
and home boarded in
in naples italy
and it was a very active
signal bridge one of the most active in
in the sixth fleet at the time
and so i go from
a signalman school to a ship that
doesn't
need
signaling to a ship that
has a very very intense uh signalman
but after that i went uh i got out
halloween on uh 69
and same question to you i mean were you
thinking to yourself was one of the
reasons you got out because you're
thinking hey this crazy thing just
happened to me i lost so many of my
friends
and now i'm told i can never talk about
it again did that impact the way you
thought about your career
interesting thing about that um
on the slovenia there was a uh
a
career counselor and every time you were
getting short he would call you into his
office and give you a long spiel about
why you should trip over and stay in the
navy
so he didn't know he didn't know me
personally and he didn't know my history
so he called me into his office and sat
down
and he says well matters
you're getting short you're thinking
about shipping over and i said no
and he and he said why just because i
was on the liberty and he said goodbye
yeah roger that phil what was the rest
of your career like
well i i joined february 6 and got out
december the 1964
and i got out december the 12th 1967
i stayed out for a couple years and i
wasn't gonna ship over either because i
i was done
but then uh
you know here i'm i'm 22 then or 23 and
i say man i'm not my life's not going
anywhere i'm not doing anything so i
really listened went back to the navy
and i got stationed for the uss maddox
dd
731 that was in the
tonkin golf tongue that's how the
vietnam war started and some of the
original crewmates were still on there
they said hey tourney that that never
happened that's all bs
it was a pretext for war that johnson
dreamed up and it turned right back
around
to uh the uss liberty
uh another pretext phony
outcome
to to keep his war machine going in
vietnam
and it's a land gravity for israel
and a
a permanent foothold in the in the area
for the united states so you when you
got to the maddox
and and they're talking about those
attacks those you know uh supposed
attacks
and the guys would say yeah it didn't
happen
yeah
no no that didn't happen the way it
worked
and uh i told a couple guys aboard there
you know my situation and my uh
uh division officer he read my file
and this is what i was getting out and
he says hey man uh
maybe you should get out because i was
uh i wasn't
i wasn't really into it
but i thought well maybe i could tough
it out
you know made a few bucks
while i was in the service but uh
that's how i was feeding my family
with you're lucky to be transferred to
the stark and then nicole
the um
as this as this cover-up continues i got
another statement here
this is from
this is from lieutenant general marshall
s carter director of the nsa
under whose authority the liberty was
operating he said couldn't be anything
else but deliberate
there's just no way you could have a
series of circumstances that would
justify this being an accident you know
as my friend darrell cooper pointed out
when this attack happened once an
international law geneva convention when
a when a naval vessel gets disabled
you're then as the attacker responsible
for trying to help
lend aid to that ship and certainly the
sailors that are that are in the water
if they're in the water
you're not supposed to be gunning up
their
lifeboats
and strafing their their the decks of
their ship as they're already a disabled
vessel so this is just wrong in every
circumstance and you know i was talking
before we started recording this you
know i've been in friendly fire
incidents before
um
in pretty bad ones where people died
and
i i totally understand that there's the
fog of war that these things happen that
that that you make mistakes and someone
sees something that they didn't think
they saw or someone saw something that
they didn't think they see
there's all things that there's a lot of
chaos that happens
but to have that happen for
hours upon hours
when there's an american flag flying you
know and and you know joe that was
again this is something else we were
joking about when we were off air
you know since you were a signalman with
no other ships to signal to you really
had one job and that was to know what
was flying what the ship was flying and
you know 100
that that that the american flag was
clearly visible
and that you actually ended up raising
an even bigger american flag that's
right
you know i i might add to that uh
jocko
the uh israeli
war room had us plotted on their map
as american and friendly
they said they changed the watch
and inadvertently forgot we were there
and took us off the war table
i mean come on man don't you know when
you when you change watches you you
inform everybody of what's going on
and they just took it all away and
that's that's
still irritates me i know it does these
guys too yeah and by the way there's no
more important piece of information on
the battlefield than where your friendly
forces are yes sir so this isn't like we
oh well whatever you know we're just
gonna pull some people off the board no
that's
that's a sin
um
and people focus on the flying of the
flag was it flying was it not flying but
that's really
that's not that's just one of the ways
of identifying a ship you know there's
the color the structure
uh how the the deck is laid out you know
the the masts and all that stuff
and they claim that they approached
within a thousand yards and
misidentified it says a
40 year old black hole rusted out
egyptian steamer half our size
jq tony hart
then a chief petty officer assigned to a
u.s navy relay station in morocco that
handled communications between
washington and the sixth fleet
remembered listening as defense
secretary robert mcnamara in washington
ordered rear admiral lawrence geiss
commander of the americas carrier battle
group to bring the jets home
when guys protested that the liberty was
under attack and needed help hart said
mcnamara retorted that president johnson
is not going to go to war or embarrass
an american ally
over a few sailors end quote
that's a violation of article 99 of the
ucmj
it is indeed
yes
article 99 of the ucmj you have to go
out and attack the enemy and you have to
go out and support your other troops
that's article 99 yes
[Applause]
statement by cia director at the time of
the attack richard helms in a 1984
interview
he said everything possible was done to
keep from the american public really the
enormity of this attack on an american
naval vessel
since this is for the agency's record i
don't think there can be any doubt that
the israelis knew exactly what they were
doing
any statement to the effect that they
didn't know it was an american ship
is nonsense
i mean that's
that's pretty freaking clear
um
you guys got a bunch of awards
for you know for for what took place
including the medal of honor captain
mcconnell
receive the medal of honor
for for his actions
which is
strange to take the story of someone
receiving the medal of honor and not
explain what happened
that was covered up in a naval shipyard
that's where he received these medal of
honors in a shipyard not at the white
house where
he could be recognized for
being the skipper of our our ship and
getting the medal of honor because it
brings too much heat on and
unfortunately i think that the captain
was
between a real rock and a hard place
on one hand
he can be treated like a hero
on the other hand he can we can be
treated like a zero
and he went with hero
i'm not saying he didn't deserve it i'm
just saying that
he clammed up and it was years and years
later 100 years later he finally said
well yeah i think it was a
it was a planned attack that was i think
there's a copy of his retirement speech
you can watch it online i've watched it
and i think it was his retirement speech
where he says
hey we need to find out the truth we
need to tell the truth about what
actually happened yes sir
he wouldn't even join the lba i tried
for years to get him to join but he says
it's too political
uh for him to get involved and finally
he did join the association after years
and years
which we were glad to see
dean rusk who was secretary of the state
at the time said i was never quote i was
never satisfied with israeli explanation
their sustained attack to disable and
sink liberty
precluded an assault by an accident or
some trigger-happy local commander
through diplomatic channels we refuse to
accept their explanations i didn't
believe them then and i don't believe
them now the attack was outrageous
um
you know some of the things that you
already talked about there's a there's a
bbc documentary called dead in the water
it's it's
you know one of the things that it said
is what you said earlier phil which is
hey if the israelis could get the
americans into this war in a big way you
know that can really help us out against
these arabs is what israeli was thinking
and
these kind of things happen
um
what is what do you guys do with the lva
now what's what's the purpose
how can people help
well
one of the things that we're still
trying to do is get recognition for our
34 fallen shipmates
we've tried over the years to get
congress to
conduct a full and impartial
investigation
and it's fallen on deaf ears
right now we've got
a resolution going forward
to
to ask for june 8th
to be
declared as uss
liberty remembrance day
it should be a fairly
simple thing for congress to do
i mean we have national
hot dog day and national you know ice
cream day
but let's have a national uss liberty
remembrance day
and
not just one year but
every year
june 8th right um
so we're working on that i've got a
resolution in the state of new york
going through the american legion up
there
um
to have that presented through
their channels
um i'm in a process of doing it in the
state of maryland
um i'm working with a
former senator pete mccluskey
to get
a petition
out
to get signatures for people that will
support the establishment of june 8th
this uss liberty remembrance day and
then present that to various legislators
to uh
show them that
hey the american public
wants to know
they need to know and
you know
if nothing else you're you're honoring
the 34 men that gave the ultimate
sacrifice
back on june 8th 1967
when when you talk about some of the
awards that were
received
most every one of us that received any
kind of an award purple heart or bronze
star you know the congressional medal of
honor it was all done
in private
there were no big ceremonies like you
would normally expect for
you know someone
with that just came off the most
decorated ship in the united states navy
since world war ii
and
you know 95 percent of the american
public's not even aware of it
so you know jacob excuse me but he said
something very interesting about the
american legion
which uh fires me up because uh
about four or five years ago um
glenn oliphant and ernie gallo our
former president
were at the convention in the american
legion and they're wanting to get a
booth and things like this
and they wouldn't allow it
uh for us to get a booth so
glenn oliphant he was so disappointed
and upset
he tore up his american legion card
right there
and he didn't throw it at anybody he
just sprinkled it right there and the
girl said
one of the
organizers
he assaulted me and they threw his ass
in jail
why wouldn't they let you have a booth
because they said uh the uss liberty
is non uh is is not essential we don't
recognize you guys
and don't ever come back because you're
banned from the american legion for life
this this is from their national
convention um
it's
still in effect today
um that we can't have a booth
when he's talking about ernie and
glenn going to that
national convention
they went there with the understanding
that we had already paid our thousand
dollar entry fee
and they got there
and were told that they hadn't received
the check and and they hadn't received
the check
so
ernie pulled out his credit card and
said
i'll pay for it right now we're here
we're we want a booth and they said no
you can't do that and then i think it
got to be somewhat confrontational
um
and
that's when
you know glenn got
upset
tore up his
you know
membership card and uh
we've tried in vain since then to get
senior management in the american legion
national organization
to
reinstate us so that we can have a booth
there that's how we tell our story
that's how we get other patriots to
you know
go back to their home states and say hey
let's let's try and do something in
support of the uss liberty i wrote up
a couple of years ago resolutions for
every state in the union
this was done at the vfw
uh national convention and i had a
representative from from each state take
one of these resolutions back for their
legislators to
consider and introduce in their state
legislator
later
and
i i don't know that anything ever came
of it
and that's that's the problem with a lot
of this trying to get people to
stand up and
and say hey if you want our support
we'll support you just like your
audience today
if there's people out there that are
willing to
you know
pick up the the torch and run with it
i'll be more than happy to write up a
resolution for any organization that
they have
and ask them to support the
establishment of the
june 8th uss liberty remembrance day
do you guys have a website yes yes and
what's that
uss libertyveterans.org yeah
i think you you take care of that don't
you joe uh well actually it's uh we have
a webmaster for it oh okay that the one
i take care of is uss
libertyveterans.blog
yeah yeah
to to donate uh
anybody out there wants to help the
liberty veterans continue on to doing
what we're doing we're a small
organization now a lot of the guys have
already passed on
uh you know
well older guys we just lost uh
commander lewis he was 92 i think yeah
and he just died this year and uh a good
man a brave man he's he's also in the uh
sacrificing liberty and i think you're
really going to get a good insight to
what went on jocko because it is uh
sacrificing liberty to me is probably
the most interesting
uh
truthful documentary that's ever been
done
in my view and i think you would
probably agree yeah i would it's um
you've got eyewitness accounts being
taken
into account
through uh through the four different
you know one hour discs
um
so it's it's not a quick read you gotta
you gotta devote some time to it but
it's certainly well worth going through
it
and uh and hearing
from
probably what a half a dozen or so of us
survivors
um
and uh
true news did an excellent job on that i
just uh
i can't say enough about how they uh
did their research not just with with us
but with other
authors and
i guess senior politicians
so that uh
it's the most factual account that i i'm
aware of
us liberty survivors are in a unique
position in american history and us navy
history
we're the only crew
in u.s navy history
that has the task of lobbying
the dod and congress to investigate
attack on our ship
and
we we don't have any experience at that
we don't know anybody who does
but we need help from people who do
we'd love to have a
a professional approach us and and offer
his services we can't pay him we don't
have any money
but we need we need professional help in
uh lobbying in in uh
in the legal legal arena i don't know if
i don't know if if there's any legal
steps we can take we were in military we
were it was our job to uh
to uh go where we're supposed to go and
do what we're supposed to do but whether
we're civilians on the ship too
do you guys feel like there's been
progress
towards getting the truth out there
because to me i mean
when i hear about the uss liberty now i
immediately kind of
most people know sort of the underlying
story
that it was an attack it was from israel
that
you know
the u.s navy lost
a bunch of sailors they don't
necessarily know how many
but do you guys feel like there's
progress been made in this story getting
out there and the truth getting out
there there's progress being made but
not to the extent that people who who
can do something about it do something
about it
so what is it that what would be the the
win what would be victory for you all
i'm sitting in the winner's circle right
now with you doing this
i feel like a winner and uh i think
these two gentlemen feel the same i mean
i i want to mention my shipmates they
all know about this and i'm sure they're
going to download this and watch it but
a special thanks you know to
mo schaefer and his wife donna he's
the money man he takes care of the money
what little we have
and uh they have a ship store you can
buy things from
and it's just uh
our way of trying to give give back
the real story
and in the last three or four years
jocko we've made more progress than we
have in the last 55 because
of sacrificing liberty
and
now here we are with you
and possibly joe rogan is going to get a
call from you and say hey you better get
these boys on
i could try
that's a long list of people trying to
go on on mr rogan's podcast i can
guarantee you that
well the win for me is a congressional
investigation okay
complete and comprehensive redundant to
be sure but it needs to be said
congressional investigation but that's a
two-edged sword
because
members of congress have refused to
investigate the attack on our ship
war crimes is a u.s statute
accessory after the fact is a u.s
statute oh
so members of congress who were in a
position to conduct an investigation
refused to
despite being lobbied by
victims of those war crimes
might stand accused of being accessories
after the fact and i don't think
accessories after the fact
is covered under congressional immunity
so there's some scared yeah yeah
congress people out there
there's some statute of limitations on
murder
a nun and that's what happened they
murdered these men and tried to murder
us i mean you know
i
i call the fbi as cia and i tell them
hey i'm an eyewitness to murder and they
get all excited until i tell them what
it's all about they said well that's
that's really uh no it's never mind
that's what we've been investigating
we've never had an investigation except
the the phony uh board of inquiry and we
got letters back from congress somewhere
in the earth that i brought to show you
there's been multiple investigations
there's never been none they're lying to
us we're eyewitnesses
to to what happened and they're telling
us we've been it's been a congressional
investigation at least three or four
times there's never been a congressional
investigation they lie to us what do you
think they're telling the american
people yeah
um
probably a good place to wrap it up i
mean that that sounds like we know what
we want to do to to move this thing
forward the congressional investigation
get the word out there let's make june
8th you know national day of remembrance
for the uss liberty um
larry just any closing thoughts from you
no i i just encourage your listeners to
um
you know take what we've said today
and
if they have any interest at all in
trying to support
the liberty
go to our website
contact us you know our contact
information is on the website
and like i said i'm willing to
draft resolutions or
petitions whatever they want for their
organization to get signatures to take
before their legislators and
try and get support for this recognition
for our fallen shipmates that
that should have happened 55 years ago
um
indeed
on our blog there's a uss
libertyveterans.blog
there's a tab that says i think it's
help us out and in that tab or a series
i think four letters you can write to uh
you can just fill in the blank and
submit
one is calling for a uh
have a member of congress send you a
copy of the congressional investigations
and they can't do it
one is asking them to
contact the congressional research
service and ask them to
has the
u.s government investigated the attack
and we got a response from one i've been
trying for years and one finally
actually asked the congressional
research service and he said no
another one asks
for congress to allow their boilerplate
responses to members to constituents who
write asking about the attack
stop using
israeli
talking points
use uss liberty survivors talking points
and uh
you know
this easy way to for them to get
involved
and then when they get the responses
send them to us and we can draft a a
response for them to uh to send
yep that that's uh the old the old
letter writing campaign yeah let's get
let's get them that way
um anything else joe i think that's it
phil any closing thoughts uh yes uh in
closing i
encourage your listeners and watchers
that all download this
share it with everybody pass the word
around
write your senators and congressmen and
let them know that the real deal is that
you you've been lying about this all the
time and we know it but they don't want
to come back and tell them tell
everybody that they're liars anyway i
mean it's going to be hard i mean
the congress and everything it's going
to take the people people your listeners
to help us out people that
watch sacrifice on liberty go to
sacrifice at liberty.com
and uh god bless you for having us on
your you're a good man and all of you i
appreciate it so much god bless you and
one thing i forgot to mention since your
blog is posted on your youtube site
there's a comment section
and we'd we'd be happy to enter into a
dialogue with anybody
on that uh on that comment section
whether they're pro-israeli
think they're pro-israeli or on the u.s
side
the comments
will definitely be there okay good we
look forward to it well uh thanks for
coming you know that these these
the conjecture and the mystery around
all these events
they've been around for a while but um i
think there's one thing that there's
absolutely no mystery about one thing
that cannot be disputed and that's the
courage and the valor and the sacrifice
of the brave sailors
of the uss liberty so thank you for
coming on thank you for
sharing your story
um thank you all personally for your
service and your sacrifice and we won't
forget what you did for the country and
nor will we ever forget the memory of
your 34 shipmates
who gave their lives
and who embodied the navy ethos
of honor courage and commitment we
commit to not forgetting their sacrifice
thank you thank you yes thank you thanks
for coming guys thank you
and with that
joe and larry and phil have left the
building echo did you know anything
about the uss liberty prior to today oh
i have heard things um not
at the end of the day no let's say
there's level five knowledge
i was at level 0.5
so you knew it existed yeah but you
didn't know too much about it yeah like
when you
i when you said
that they were coming on and you said
the uss liberty i was like i was like
okay it wasn't like just in the dark it
wasn't a shot in the dark for me no yeah
so it's too bad more people don't know
about it
and i'm glad that they were able to come
on and and share the story and it just
you know just really
it is kind of crazy and i think we've
done i've done some you know obviously
we've done some podcasts about
well about mcnamara for sure
and i'm not a i don't like mcnamara i
don't like the way he led i don't like
the way he did things
and
so this is just like another
nail in the coffin for mcnamara from my
perspective
to to know that
you know he
was one of the people that allowed this
stuff to happen and lbj the same thing
president johnson same thing you know
president johnson
it just shows you the level of kind of
corruption and ineptitude that the
leadership had
and and what's i don't really what
really bothers me about it
is
you know if someone's not capable and
they end up in a position you're like
you know if if echo if you're supposed
to be doing something and you don't have
the capability of doing it
i i'm probably not i'm not gonna be mad
at you you know i'm not gonna get mad at
you
but if you're capable that you're doing
things a certain way for
because you think you're smarter than
everybody else or you think you can
outsmart the
american people or you think you can
outsmart you know your your boss or
whatever and you you're trying to
maneuver i'm going to have a problem
with that so i'm going to have more of a
problem with i actually have a lot more
of a problem with someone that's just
hey echo had this idea this is what he
thought was going to happen it didn't go
that way
okay you know got it
he's not capable of doing it he didn't
understand the situation like he can't
get mad at someone's lack of ability to
do something but if echo was smart
and you were in there and you made
decisions that actually made things go a
certain way
that's gonna make me mad and that's how
i feel about mcnamara and johnson and
so there you go so what
okay so
government's claiming mistaken identity
they're claiming
what like what exactly what's the
explanation there are several
explanations the main thing that what
the what the government says
i shouldn't say it's all the government
because not all the government says this
this cover-up at the time was he was
mistaken identity it was a you know
unfortunate incident
the the israeli said sorry we're
carrying on with our mission
there's two there's two real
explanations one of them is
that hey the israelis didn't want
americans listening so they attacked the
ship
and there's one that is the israelis
wanted
they wanted america to enter the war
and they knew that america would enter
the war if one of the american ships was
attacked by
these arab forces
and so they tried to do it in such a way
that because you wouldn't think the
israelis would do that i mean that's
like crazy right yeah those are actual
allies so how could this happen it must
have been the you know it was obviously
the arabs there's no survivors
the ship is sunk and gone
we better go
pay
the arab nations back for sinking our
ship right
so is it out of the question that people
do that kind of thing not at all
not at all false flag attacks like
that's a literal false flag attack so
and look i don't really even know
how debatable it even is
you know like this is the israelis have
admitted that they attacked the ship
they've said hey it was a mistake
we're sorry it wasn't that long it
wasn't that bad we didn't shoot up
there's there's some where they directly
conflict with
no we didn't shoot up the lifeboats the
lifeboats they said they didn't do that
so they're they they kind of claim it
they kind of downplay it and claim it as
a mistake that's sort of the cover-up
the cover-up is downplayed it was a
mistake the reality is
at least
at least admit the full extent of what
happened
and then on top of that was it
intentional
did you actually
want to do this to drag americans into
this war
and then
if you wanted to do that and the people
that called off the
support to the vessel
are americans you knew about it right
so
that's why these guys are calling for a
full congressional investigation
a congressional inquiry to figure out
exactly what happened so people can be
held accountable and not only so people
can be held accountable but so you can
look back and say hey here's the
mistakes that we made we put too much
power in this position we we
allowed our allies to do too much we
didn't run through
the chain of command like there's a
bunch of things that you can learn from
it and to not break it down with the
inquiry like that and find out what
actually happened i mean a seven-day
inquiry i mean
phil brought in a stack of papers he's
got all kinds of information about this
you couldn't even cover that information
in seven day inquiry
so
yeah that's it
you kind of
in a way draw the line in the sand when
you start like lying and then telling
people to be like hey you're not allowed
to talk about this or whatever that's
like okay no and even that i you know as
i said on the podcast
there are some things for national
security
where this is what happened and you
can't talk about it anymore hey all the
sog guys weren't allowed to talk about
the secret war for 20 years yeah that's
what actually happened they signed a
paper and said they couldn't talk about
it those are that's classified
information you're not allowed to talk
about it
what's what makes it disturbing in this
one is it doesn't seem like the national
security in a straightforward manner was
in jeopardy
what was in jeopardy was the
relationship with israel the political
standing of because if let's face it if
the america would have found out that
somehow our own government was involved
in attack on one of our own ships like
that's game over for the entire
administration
so what are they going to do
hey don't say anything to anybody
to protect their own ass
and this is not beyond a guy like
johnson and not beyond a guy like
mcnamara
yeah so
these politicians that think they're
smart
um horrible stuff so
uh if you want to support them
you can go to uss liberty vets
liberty veterans uss libertyveterans.org
or uss
libertyveterans.blog that's where you
can go to support them
if you want to get a bunch of more
information about it there's a movie
that phil pointed out sacrificing
liberty so check out that movie also
phil's written a couple books one of
them called holocaust on the high seas
by phil turney the other one is called
erasing the liberty
the battle to keep alive the memory of
israel's massacre on the uss liberty
so there's two books you can pick up
that were were written by phil tourney
who you heard talking today
as far as the podcast goes as far as you
go
really
if you want to support the podcast you
want to support yourself check out check
out some jockofuel.com
it's true finally you have some
healthy
supplements not with the uh negative
side effects the negative side effects
yep
finally oh what was that what's the
contest we got going we've got some
contests it'll probably be over by now
but i don't know it's like the battle of
el of the flames yeah battles the
flavors we're giving someone a year's
worth a go what is that one go a day
you think
sure it's a lot of gold man
yes sir uh yes also yes some good
tasting protein this is all stuff that
is going to keep us really on the path
really been on the path we had a
birthday party this past weekend yeah i
know i didn't make it slipped off the
path a little bit would you what'd you
do some cupcakes cupcakes i don't like
cupcakes matter of fact i don't really
even like cake no cake no okay no what's
the jam you said it's dry tastes dry to
me
so what's your jammer actually i already
know this
i know the pigs in a blanket situation i
know you like that that's a good one
but what about dessert oh uh chocolate
uh mint chocolate chip ice cream yes we
did have that too by the way yeah did
you buy that in case i showed up
trying to tempt me trying to bring me
down no my kids like that trying to
negatively impact my life that's what
you're doing you know i would have just
had a milk a mint molk yeah which isn't
equivalent
no but you do a good bad job of eating
these cakes and whatnot if the kids are
around and they want to have something
with you
what do you mean i do a good bat slash
bad job because you do good job bonding
with the kids but meanwhile you're
sleeping on the path it's like what do
you call a tactical
little catch-22 little tactical
sacrifice for a strategic win yep yeah
and then you're teaching your kids how
to eat cake
i know
there's a there's al there's a saying in
the
in the i don't know might be the whole
navy but it might be the whole military
but we'd say like let them eat cake you
know so that also we call the officers
cake eaters oh damn okay so i heard that
before cake eater so i wouldn't eat cake
it was like a thing like i wouldn't kind
of like now i don't eat doughnuts right
right like out of the principle yeah
just out of principle i probably never
be able to have a doughnut again for the
rest of my life because there's gonna be
someone with a 600 millimeter telephoto
lens and i'll be on the cover of the
freaking
national and quieter jock was a liar yep
it's true very possible so no doughnuts
over here but we will have some more we
will have some joint warfare some super
krill
jackalful.com you can get the stuff to
vitamin shop you can get the drinks at
wawa we got some um
we got ready to drink
protein shakes coming yeah which is a
kind of a game changer right when you
just roll into a store you're hungry
yeah you need that you're you're
starting to go catabolic
oh yeah and you need that little hitter
yeah plus is a perfect mix you know yeah
it's ensured the perfect mix yeah it's
just good to go so we got those coming
shortly so yep jocklefield.com check it
out if you want to check it out some
good stuff on there also american-made
stuff american-made denim some hunting
stuff coming yeah
yeah face it the hype around that is
significant yes sir well it's a big deal
to make stuff in america i actually saw
somebody commented on one of the youtube
videos and said yeah but
what do you do when stuff's made in
america but the components are from
overseas our components are not from
overseas no sir our components are from
america yeah the the materials made in
america grown
the cotton cotton the components for the
components is made in the middle that's
what we're saying so yeah when you go to
origin usa you are supporting not just
origin usa you are supporting the entire
the entire supply chain that runs down
to the fields in texas
the fields in south carolina the
factories in south carolina the mills
and south carolina
you're feeding the entire
system
by supporting origin usa so check out
originusa.com
and you're not supporting uniquely
affordable labor
oh slave labor wait wait was that the
new youth euphemism uniquely supportable
uh i think that's what
they called it on the thing that i
watched
uniquely affordable labor yeah we call
that slave labor yes that's what that's
called and we don't do it yeah we have
awesome workers
american workers that are doing a great
job and get and have skill
and bring it to the table every day and
work their ass off to make these
products so there you go originalusa.com
check that out also you want to
represent you want to wear we got some
good shirts we're having we have a new
shirt we have all new stuff coming soon
very soon just clinicals freedom shirts
hoodies new designs new designs oh
really you went ham huh well well you
know i figured that we all kind of
wanted a little bit of an update you
know still still uh consistent i would
say but a good one anyway dracostore.com
that's where you can get your shirts and
hats and hoodies and merch if you want
to represents good spot oh look at that
guy with the merc
what's the has the has the latest shirt
locker shirt that i designed
on the market yet is it out there yeah
so people had it have had it delivered
march
that's kind of
that's kind of cool that they have no
idea what's coming and it just shows up
oh yeah yeah it might be super dope yeah
in this case it is recently apparently
according to the field so every once in
a while those who have my phone number
or on twitter or
the gram
they um
they'll send me a picture of them with
the shirt on and they they will say
you nailed it with this one or whatever
yeah
and i've been getting a lot of those
recently for the past
three months damn yeah two minutes of
consistent goodness existing from the ec
uh so yeah check out the show locker
there uh subscribe to this podcast don't
don't forget about jocko underground
jockowunderground.com we've been doing
we've been doing a lot of q and a on
there only because we have a place where
people that are members of jocko
underground.com can email so we've been
going through all those questions
and
yes at some point we backed off doing q
and a on this podcast probably because
the questions were overwhelming in
numbers so now we kind of narrow that
down that's one of the things that we're
doing on jack underground.com if you got
a question you can email it there it
costs eight dollars and 18 cents a month
that's how we keep it up and running
that's also our escape
hatch
if we get banned or
censored or de-platformed for whatever
reason
and if you can't afford that we still
want you in the game you can just email
assistance at underground at jaw
assistance jockowunderground.com so
check that out
you know also youtube we do have a
youtube channel video versions podcasts
yeah check down also origin usa origin
hd yeah that's a good youtube channel as
well then follow along
how
an american company from top to bottom
is run very interesting now
yeah
uh psychological warfare you can check
up flip flip side canvas we got
we got dakota just just
out there getting after in 74 different
directions which is awesome he's doing
all kinds of stuff he's got a gym he's a
firefighter he's a pilot a helicopter
pilot so dakota meyer he's got another
business which is called
flipsidecanvas.com
and you can get cool stuff to hang on
your wall there hey and for books look
the books i just mentioned um erasing
liberty by phil terney we got
his other book holocaust on the high
seas
there's also a book called remember the
liberty by
philip nelson and ron kucal which i ron
put this podcast together today i
mentioned him so you can check out his
book
also
speaking of doing a bunch of different
things we got jocko publishing and jocko
publishing has published some books
published mikey and the dragons publish
way the warrior kid
three and four
also holly mckay
she wrote a book called only cry for the
living and right now she's been in
afghanistan iraq syria she's a war
reporter right now she's on the ground
in ukraine
she was in keeve today
so
check out holly mckay and if you want to
support her get her book only cry for
the living
you can get that at jocklepublishing.com
or you can get it on amazon or whatever
so then you got all the books that i've
written
uh i think there's some kind of a
special coming out on final spin so i'm
kind of special on this is amazon
uh leadership strategy taxes on all my
books check those out if you want to
appreciate it echelon front that's my
leadership consulting company where we
solve problems through leadership
leadership is the solution
we just sold out the texas muster
um so if you want to come to a muster if
you want to go to any of our events just
go to
echelonfront.com and check out the
details of what we do how you can
utilize us to help your company
we also have extreme ownership academy
extreme ownership.com speaking of asking
me questions come on there and literally
ask me a question i'll be on a zoom call
on monday
and you can ask me whatever you want
i'll be on there the next monday i'll be
there on wednesday i'll be there on
friday come and check it out there's a
bunch of courses you can take it's just
it's a really powerful platform check
out extremeownership.com if you want to
help in your life look it's not like oh
you're a leader and you're in charge of
1400 people or you're a leader you're in
charge of seven people you don't have to
be in charge of it you're in charge of
your own life
and if you want to learn about how to
better lead your own life
go to extreme ownership.com yeah i feel
like
and this might be just me it could be
everybody but i feel like when you hear
the word leader it kind of comes from
when you're a kid and it's like follow
the leader like me the boss everyone
follow me kind of a thing
physically like actually literally
following me whatever but
as it turns out
it's like essentially the ability to
make the right calls and the right
decision in every situation even if
you're by yourself by the way yeah yeah
so yeah it's like it's almost like a
leader might not even be the most
best word
to say it that'll land on your brain the
way yeah the reality is almost like
learn how to live your life in the best
possible way yeah
check
if you want to live your life in the
best possible way you want to learn how
to make decisions what decisions to make
because that's where your life is a
series of decisions how are you doing
that how are you mitigating risk how are
you figuring out where to take chances
how are you figuring out where you need
to reinforce certain parts of your life
how are you figuring out how you're
going to interact with this person that
has a huge part in your life whether you
want them to or not all kinds of things
to learn
that's all extremeownership.com if you
want to help service members active and
retired their families
gold star families everybody that has
served if you want to help them go to
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got an
incredible charity organization if you
want to donate or you want to get
involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org also don't forget
about horses and heroes
no heroes and horses i always get that
one backwards yeah the horses come first
in my mind the heroes should come first
heroes and horses.com
micah fink doing awesome stuff with his
charity organization
ekko and i if you want to hear more from
us then you can go on the social media
of course
surgeon general warning watch out for
the algorithm because he's getting ready
to grab you by the trout
and try and drag you in there echoes
adequate charles i am a jocko willing
and thanks once again to joe larry and
phil for your service and sacrifice and
thanks to all the sailors of the uss
liberty
especially those 34 brave souls
who sacrificed their lives
for their shipmates
and thanks to all the rest of the
sailors out there from the world's
finest navy
that are on the high seas 365 days a
year
protecting the cause of freedom around
the world
and thanks to the rest of our military
that fights
on the land and in the air to protect
our way of life
and also to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service all first
responders who protect us here at home
thank you for what you do
and everyone else
you never know what you're going to run
into
you never know what's going to happen
you never know who is going to attack
you and these guys talked about it today
they were prepared they were ready they
were vigilant
so when something unfolds
you are prepared like they were to
behave like they did the brave sailors
of the uss liberty and don't ever give
up
and until next time
this is echo and jocko
out